BEGIN BY WELCOMING ALL OF YOU
TO OUR JOINT OVERSIGHT HEARING
OF THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
AND THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
CYBERSECURITY TODAY SO HEARING
IS THREE A TRIFOLD IN FACT
FIRST IT IS TO PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE PUBLIC TO
HEAR FROM THE STATE AUDITOR ON
A RECENT REPORT ON THE STATUS
OF THOSE STATES INFORMATION
SECURITY AND CYBERSECURITY
READINESS SECOND IT IS TO HEAR
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY WHICH LEADS TO STAY
IN ITS EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES ANYMORE. AW UNIFY
FASHION ON THE AUDIT FINDINGS
AND INFORMATION SECURITY
STANDARDS THIRD IT IS TO ALLOW
AS THE OPPORTUNITY TO FURTHER
DISCUSS THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS I ALSO WANNA
THANK ALL MY A CO CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR A WIN FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON CYBERSECURITY
SHOES. AND AS CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON
CYBERSECURITY THESE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS SHE HAS BEEN A
GREAT CHAMPION AND RESOLUTE
DOUBT PARTNER IN A SHORT EFFORT
TO FIND A SOLUTION. TO THE
ISSUE OF INFORMATION SECURITY
AND CYBERSECURITY CAPS I ALSO
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS WHO IS THE CHAIR OF THE
JOINT. LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE FOR HIS PARTICIPATION
HERE TODAY I AS CHAIR OF J.
LACK AND FELLOW MEMBER OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON
CYBERSECURITY I PARTICULARLY
APPRECIATE HIS RECORD OF
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE OUR
PRIOR EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. I ALSO LIKE THE ALSO
THINK THE OTHER MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMITTEE FOR JOINING US HERE
TODAY MISTER OBERNOLTE AND ALSO
A MISTER KILEY. ON THE ISSUE OF
STATE INFORMATION SECURITY AND
GAPS IN OVERSIGHT HAS BEEN OF
INTEREST TO US FOR SOMETIME NOW
IN FACT SOME OF YOU MAY RECALL
THAT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN I
INTRODUCED A BILL. AB THIRTY.
ONE NINETY THREE THAT WAS JOIN
THE AUTHORED BY CHAIR. WOMEN
IRWIN AND ALL FELLOW ON. MEMBER
OF A FROM A PRICE COMMITTEE
MISTER OBERNOLTE ON THIS VERY
EXACT ISSUES SPECIFICALLY THE
BILL SOUGHT TO REQUIRE ALL
AGENCIES. AND NOT ONLY DOES
UNDER DIRECT AUTHORITY OF THE
GOVERNOR TO COMPLY WITH THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES OF THE
OFFICE OF INFORMATION SECURITY
OR I. S. WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY WHICH
IS C. T. T. UNFORTUNATELY THE
BILL WAS OPPOSED BY.
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS WHO
SOUGHT TO REMAIN INDEPENDENT
FROM ANY A BURDENS OF
RESPONSIBILITY FINANCIAL OR
OTHERWISE WHICH DID NOT ALIGN
WITH THEIR- OF PRIORITIES. NOW
THE AUDITOR'S RECENT REPORT
COMPLETELY VALIDATES THE X.
CONCERNS ON THAT THE- MY
COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE HAD. AND
SHOWS THAT MANY OF THE ENTITIES
THAT DO NOT REPORT TO THE CDT
HAVE INDEED HIGH RISKS
DEFICIENCIES AND MANY ARE
UNAWARE. OF INFORMATION
SECURITY WEAKNESSES AT ALL. OUT
IN MY OPENING REMARKS BY
ADMITTING THAT THIS MIGHT NOT
SEEM LIKE THE MOST THRILLING
TOPIC ON PAPER. BUT EVERY TIME
WE HAVE A BREACH AND DATA BE IT
ON THE PRIVATE SIDE FOR EXAMPLE
WITH THE TARGET EQUIFAX
FACEBOOK OVER OTHERS. OR THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE STATE SIDE OF
THE PUBLIC IS RIGHTFULLY
FRIGHTENED AND WE FIND
OURSELVES DEALING WITH. THE
AFTERMATH OFTENTIMES. IF WE
WANT TO CHANCE AT REDUCING
THESE EVENTS ON THE STATE SIDE
WE HAVE TO. FOCUS UP AND BE
MORE PROACTIVE RATHER THAN
REACTIONARY I BELIEVE A
STARTING WITH HEARINGS LIKE THE
ONE THAT WE HAVING A TODAY. I'M
VERY MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE DISCUSSION TODAY AND HOPE
THAT WITH THE FINDINGS OF THE
RECENT REPORT OUR LEGISLATIVE
EFFORTS TO BRING ALL STAY
ENTITIES ON THE ONE UNIFORM IF
NATION'S SECURITY APPROACH.
WILL FINALLY MAKE IT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK SO WITH .ORG
I'M GONNA TURN IT OVER TO CHAIR
WOMEN IRWIN. FOR ON HER OPENING
REMARKS. AT THIS TIME
. THIRTY
SINCE ITS INCEPTION. I'VE
WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH MY
COLLEAGUES BOTH IN LEGISLATIVE
AND EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO MAKE
SURE WE UNDERSTAND THE THREATS
THAT ARE FACING US AND ARE
APPROPRIATELY PREPARED TO FACE
THEM. WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY
SINCE THE STATE AUDITOR. I
RELEASED HER FIRST REPORT WHICH
IDENTIFIED INFORMATION SECURITY
AS A HIGH RISK AREA FOR OUR
STATE. WITH A FOCUS ON BUILDING
UP OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
NETWORKS THE MANDATING BETTER
TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO USE OUR
REPORTING ENTITIES HAVE HAD
TIME TO BUILD AN IMPORTANT
FOUNDATION OF SECURITY. THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO BUILD ON. THE
REPORT WE ARE HERE FOR TODAY
IS. TO BRING INTO FOCUS A
PROBLEM THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS SEAT AND OF FOR SEVERAL
YEARS SOME PARTS OF OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT THOSE NON REPORTING
AGENT ENTITIES HAVE BEEN ARE
BLIND SPOT. THEY HAVE NOT HAD
THE OVERSIGHT THAT RESULTED IN
IMPORTANT OUTCOMES FOR THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH. WELL IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN MY SINCERE HOPE
THAT THE REPRESENTATIVES. OF
REPRESENTATIONS OF MANY OF THE
NON REPORTING ENTITIES WERE
TRUE THAT THEY WERE MEETING
EVERY STANDARD AND THAT THEY
WERE KEEPING OUR CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SECURE THIS
REPORT. CONFIRMS THAT THOSE
HOPES WERE SOMEWHAT MISPLACED
WITH TODAY'S HEARING I'M READY
TO DIG INTO THE DETAILS WITH
THE AUDITOR AND HER TEAM. AND
TO GET CONTACTS AN EXPERT
KNOWLEDGE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY SO THAT WE CAN
TAKE CONCRETE STEPS TO LEVERAGE
THE FULL FORCE OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN SOLVING THE LACK
OF FOCUS ON CYBERSECURITY AND
NON REPORTING ENTITIES. AND NOW
I WOULD LIKE TO. TURN THE GAVEL
OVER SORT OF. TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN FOR
HAVING ME HERE AS WELL. I DO
THINK THIS IS A VERY EXCITING
TOPIC IS A VERY EXCITING TOPIC
ESPECIALLY FOR NOW WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE WORLD TODAY. YOU KNOW
WE CAN READ WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH A AYE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND HOW THAT'S
BEING INTEGRATED WITH FACIAL
RECOGNITION. SOFTWARE WE CAN
READ WE READ ABOUT WHAT BIG BIG
DATA ACTUALLY MEANS THE WEATHER
WHERE WHETHER YOU'RE LOOKING AT
ANALYTICA OR EVEN THINGS THAT
HAPPENED IN THE LAST ELECTION
CYCLE OR TO OUR OWN SHOPPING
HABITS. I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE I TALK TO THEY FEEL LIKE
THEIR PHONE SPYING ON THEM
BECAUSE- EVERY TIME THEY GO TO
LOOK AT AN ARTICLE THEY SEE
SOMETHING THAT THEY JUST SHOP
FOR. RIGHT REMINDING THEM TO.
TO PURCHASE WHATEVER ITEM THEY
WERE JUST LOOKING AT. BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT. WHAT THAT REMINDS US
SO IS AB HOW MUCH TECHNOLOGY IS
INVOLVED IN. AND US THE STATE
LAWMAKERS NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR SYSTEMS HERE AT THE
STATE OR ACTUALLY ADEQUATELY OF
ALL THE AT THAT PACE IF NOT I
KNOW WE'RE IN A PERPETUAL CATCH
UP STATE. WITH THAT AND SO OUR
POLICIES AND SOME OF THE
LEGISLATION I KNOW EACH OF US
OF INTRODUCED AND CO AUTHOR
TOGETHER. TRY TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE POLICY THINGS I'M
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO. THE
AUDITORS WERE REPORTED HER
RECOMMENDATIONS AS SHE OUTLINED
AS WELL FOR WHAT WE CAN DO TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR STATE
AGENCIES ARE IN COMPLIANCE OR
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE IN COMPLIANCE
BECAUSE I KNOW FOR A- OF MY
CONSTITUENTS IN FOR EVERY
CALIFORNIA. THEY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR DAY JUST
PROTECTED. RIGHT THEY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT ANY INFORMATION
THAT THE HAND OVER TO THE STATE
IS PROTECTED IN ISN'T. MISUSED
OUR ARE USED IN THE NEFARIOUS
WAY AND SO I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR I KNOW WE'RE IN A-
MARATHON OF HEARINGS THIS WEEK
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS IN A
WEEK. YOUR FIRST IN REALLY LAST
NIGHT. THAT TODAY AND I KNOW
TOMORROW YOU'LL BE WIT ME
AGAIN. SO I APPRECIATE THAT AND
I APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS.
CALLING THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING DOLLAR THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT AND BEFORE I INTRODUCED
THE FIRST PANEL WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF MEMBERS HERE FROM OUR
PRIVACY COMMITTEE WOULD ANYBODY
LIKE TO MAKE A STATEMENT.
OPENING REMARKS. MR KILEY NOW
YOU ARE THE TRUSTED IN THAT.
ALL RIGHT. SO FOR THE
PRESENTATION OF THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
CALL UP ELAINE HELL'S THE STATE
AUDITOR AND THEN ALSO FROM THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE BEN WARD
WHO IS AN AUDITOR SUPERVISOR.
WELCOME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CHAIR CHAO AND CHAIR WHEN
MEMBERS OF THE RESPECTIVE
COMMITTEES FOR THE RECORD MY
NAME'S ELAINE HOW ALL ON THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR TO MY
RIGHT IS BEEN WARD BAN IS THE
AUDIT MANAGER OF OUR I. T.
AUDIT SUPPORT GROUP THIS GROUP
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO ALL OF THE
AUDIT TEAMS THAT WORK ON A
VARIETY OF ITEMS THAT THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
ASKS US OR DIRECTS US TO
CONDUCT BUT ALSO THEY DO
SPECIAL WORK FOR US AS WELL
AUDIT IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
THE VALUE THAT. THAT MY I. T.
ON A GROUP BRINGS TO THE TABLE
WHAT I INTEND TO DO VERY
QUICKLY IS GO OVER A LITTLE BIT
OF THE HISTORY OF THE STATE
AUDITOR'S WORK WITH RESPECT TO
INFORMATION SECURITY AND THEN I
WILL QUICKLY HANDED OVER TO MR
WARD AND HE WILL STEP YOU
THROUGH THE CONCLUSIONS THAT WE
REACHED IN THE MOST RECENT
REPORT WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE
REPORTS THE SERGEANT WILL BE
HANDING OUT TO MEMBERS BUT AS
AS CHAIR OR WHEN INDICATED MY
OFFICE HAS FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE WE HAVE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY. TO CREATE
WHAT'S CALLED A HIGH RISK LIST
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THIS IS STATE AGENCIES OR
PARTICULAR ISSUE AREAS THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
GRAPPLED WITH AND CONTINUES TO
STRUGGLE WITH IT SECURITY IT
PROCUREMENT ARE A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES OF ISSUES THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED IN THE PAST. WHAT
THAT. STATUTORY AUTHORITY
ALLOWS US TO DO IS USE OUR WORK
THAT WE'VE DONE ON BEHALF OF
THE LEGISLATURE WORK THAT OTHER
ENTITIES HAVE DONE PERHAPS WORK
THAT LA HAS DONE. AND REALLY
LOOK AT THESE ISSUES AND TRY
TO. LOOK AT THINGS OVER A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME RATHER THAN ONE
PARTICULAR STANDALONE AUDIT AND
THEN WE'RE DONE. SO IN IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY THIRTEEN WEEK WAS THE
FIRST. POINT IN TIME WHERE WE
IDENTIFIED IT SECURITY AS A
HIGH RISK ISSUE. THIS WAS BASED
ON AUDIT WORK THAT WE HAD DONE
ON A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
PROJECTS THE LEGISLATURE ASKED
US TO DO. BUT AGAIN IT WAS
SPOTTY IT WAS AN AUDIT OF THE
P. YOU SEE IT WAS AN AUDIT OF
THE AT THAT TIME THE A OC. AND
ONE OF THE ELEMENTS OF THOSE
AUDITS WAS LOOKING AT
PROTECTION OF DATA AND I. T.
SECURITY. SO WE DECIDED BASED
ON AN ADVICE FROM MY STAFF.
LET'S LOOK AT THIS MORE
GLOBALLY FROM A MORE GLOBAL
PERSPECTIVE AS TO WHAT IS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOING.
ACROSS THE BOARD FOR ALL OUR
STATE AGENCIES. TO ENSURE THAT.
DATA IS BEING PROTECTED TO THE
EXTENT WE POSSIBLY CAN PROTECT
IT SO. WE PUT IT ON THE HIGH
RISK LIST IN SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY THIRTEEN. THEN WE DID AN
AUDIT IN ALL AT THAT WE
RELEASED IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN. AND THIS WAS
SPECIFICALLY AN AUDIT OF
ENTITIES THAT WERE UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PURVIEW. UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGIES
PURVIEW AS FAR AS AN AND
OVERSIGHT ENTITY. AND IN THAT
AUDIT WE SURVEYED AGENCIES AND
THEN WE DID A DRILL DOWN AT
FIVE PARTICULAR ENTITIES WE
DON'T DISCLOSE THE NAMES OF THE
ENTITIES IN THE REPORT. BACK IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND YOU'LL SEE
IN THE REPORT. THAT YOU LOOK AT
TODAY WERE NOT DISCLOSING THE
NAMES OF THE ENTITIES TO
PROTECT. BECAUSE THERE ARE
VULNERABILITIES IN THERE ARE
WEAKNESSES AND WE DON'T WANT TO
DISCLOSE THAT. TO THE PUBLIC OR
ANYONE THAT WANTS TO
POTENTIALLY HACK INTO THE
SYSTEMS. SO BACK IN AUGUST OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN WE CONDUCTED THE
WORK WE SURVEYED A BUNCH OF
AGENCIES ASK THEM ABOUT THEIR
POLICIES PROCEDURES WHAT
STANDARDS DO THEY FOLLOW. WITH
RESPECT TO PERFECT. PROTECTING.
A DATA AND CALIFORNIA WERE THEY
FOLLOWING. OTHER SAM FIFTY
THREE HUNDRED STANDARDS WHICH
ARE STANDARDS THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ESTABLISHED. THAT
MIRROR NATIONAL STANDARDS. THAT
REALLY DO PUT TOGETHER A
FRAMEWORK FOR PROTECTING DATA
WHAT WE FOUND IN THAT AUDIT IS.
SEVENTY SEVEN OF THE AGENCIES I
THINK WE SURVEYED A LITTLE OVER
A HUNDRED AGENCY SAID. A
SEVENTY THREE OUT OF SEVENTY
SEVEN SAID WE ARE NOT COMPLIANT
WE KNOW WE SELL FOR SIR WE ARE
NOT COMPLIANT. WITH THERE ARE
WEAKNESSES IN OUR SYSTEMS. SO
WHEN WE WENT TO THE FIVE
ENTITIES AND DRILL DOWN. AND
REALLY TOOK A HARDER LOOK AT
WELL WHY ARE YOU NOT COMPLIANT
WILL PART OF THE REASON IS. WE
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE STANDARDS
WE NEED ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE WE
NEED SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY. CALIFORNIA'S
EXPERTS ARE IN WHAT THE
STANDARDS ARE AND WHAT KINDS OF
PROTECTIONS. THEY NEEDED
ASSISTANCE IN CONDUCTING RISK
MANAGEMENT DETERMINING WHAT ARE
THE HIGHEST RISK. ISSUES THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS FIRST SO
THAT WAS AN ISSUE THAT WE
IDENTIFIED ALSO. THERE IS
REPORTING. THAT STATE ENTITY
SUBMIT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND WHAT WE SAW IS
EVEN THOUGH THOSE AGENCIES WERE
SELF ASSERTING TO TECHNOLOGY.
THAT THERE WAS A PROBLEM THERE
WASN'T FOLLOW UP ON ON THE PART
OF TECHNOLOGY TO MAKE SURE THAT
IS AGENCIES. EITHER GOT THE
APPROPRIATE TRAINING UNDERSTOOD
THE GUIDANCE AND REALLY PUT
TOGETHER WHAT WAS REFERRED TO
AS A REMEDIATION PLAN WHAT ARE
YOUR PLANS TO ADDRESS. THE
WEAKNESSES SO WE MADE A VARIETY
OF RECOMMENDATIONS TO. ON THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY AND
CERTAINLY SOME LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND I KNOW.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHEN WE HAD
AUTHORED A BILL AT THAT TIME
AND THAT BILL. MADE IT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND THAT WAS A
BILL THAT REQUIRED AGENCIES
THIRTY FIVE A YEAR. TO HAVE A
SECURITY ASSESSMENT THAT WAS A
HUGE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AS FAR AS MANDATING.
THIS KIND OF ASSESSMENT AND
OVERSIGHT FOR AGENCIES TO
REALLY PURSUE IT BECAUSE WE SAW
A MIX OF. AGENCIES IN
DETERMINING WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WERE GOING TO DO AN ASSESSMENT
HOW COMPREHENSIVE WAS THE
ASSESSMENT. SO THERE. HAVE BEEN
STEPS AS AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN INDICATED. THAT THERE HAS
BEEN IMPROVEMENT AND LOOKING AT
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE
MADE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY BACK IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. THEY HAVE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED ALL THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS PROVIDING
GUIDANCE HAVING WORKSHOPS
LOOKING AT THE STANDARDS
GETTING FEEDBACK FROM. THEIR
CONSTITUENTS STATE AGENCIES SO
WE SAW IMPROVEMENT AT THERE
STILL IS WORK TO BE DONE. BUT
IT HAS GOTTEN BETTER SO OUR
CONCLUSION FROM THAT IS
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVERSIGHT
FROM THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
HAS HELPED THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. GET INTO A BETTER
POSITION AND PROTECTING DATA
BUT THERE WAS A MISSING LINK.
IT WAS THESE ENTITIES THAT ARE
NOT UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH UNDER THE
GOVERNOR. AND MANY OF THOSE
ENTITIES WE MEANT WE DON'T
SPECIFY BUT IT'S DO YOU
JUDICIAL BRANCH ENTITIES
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS. OTHER
ENTITIES THAT ARE NOT UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PURVIEW SO WE
DECIDED THIS LAST YEAR WE NEED
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE
AGENCIES AND DO SOMETHING
COMPARABLE. TO WHAT WE DID BACK
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN TO REALLY SEE
WHAT IS THE FRAMEWORK LOOKING
LIKE WHAT'S THE WHAT ARE THESE
DIFFERENT ENTITIES DOING
CONSTITUTIONAL THAN OTHERS. AS
FAR AS MAKING SURE THEY ADOPT
STANDARDS THEY'RE FOLLOWING
THOSE STANDARDS THEY'RE GETTING
THOSE ASSESSMENTS DONE THEY'RE
IDENTIFYING THEIR WEAKNESSES.
AND HOPEFULLY MITIGATING AND
CAR ARE CORRECTING THOSE
WEAKNESS WEAKNESSES TO TIGHTEN
UP. THE CONTROLS OVER THOSE THE
DATA THAT THEY HAVE. IN HOUSE
SO WITH THAT MEMBERS ALTERNATE
OVER TO MISTER WARD WE HAVE
HANDED OUT THE REPORTS VERY
SHORT. THERE'S A FEW TABLES IN
THE REPORT I BELIEVE MISTER
WHAT'S GONNA STEP YOU THROUGH
TO REALLY ILLUSTRATE WHAT WE
IDENTIFIED THIS PARTICULAR
REPORT. VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
IDENTIFIED BACK IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN FOR STATE AGENCIES WE
DO HAVE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONTEMPLATE. WHERE WE THINK
THERE CAN BE REPORTING. TO THE-
PRIVACY COMMITTEE AS FAR AS THE
ASSESSMENTS THAT THESE ENTITIES
ARE DOING SO THAT THERE IS
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT IT
PROTECTS THE INDEPENDENCE OF
THE CONSTITUTION. ELS ADDRESSES
THAT CONCERN BUT ALSO PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT FOR THESE
ENTITIES SO THAT WE CAN
STRENGTHEN THEIR CONTROLS OVER
INFORMATIONS INFORMATION AND
DATA THAT THEY COLLECT SO OFTEN
I'LL HAND IT OVER TO MISTER
WARD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD MY
NAME IS BEN WARD I WAS THE
AUDIT PRINCIPLE ON THIS
ASSIGNMENT. AND AS MS HOUSE
SAID THIS AUDIT FOCUSED ON
ENTITIES THAT WERE OUTSIDE THE
PURVIEW OF DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY FOR THE PURPOSES OF
THE AUDIT. WE CALL THOSE NON
REPORTING ENTITIES AND AMONG
OTHER THINGS WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THEY DON'T HAVE TO FOLLOW THE-
STATE STANDARDS FOR INFORMATION
SECURITY THERE ARE MAINTAINED
BY DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY. SO
AGAIN UNDERSTANDING OF. WHAT
STANDARDS THEY WERE FOLLOWING
AND WHAT STEPS THE NON
REPORTING AGENCIES WERE TAKING
TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAD
EFFECTIVE. I'M SECURITY
PRACTICES WE SURVEYED THIRTY
THREE ENTITIES. AND TWENTY NINE
RESPONDED SAYING THAT THEY HAD
BASED THEIR SECURITY POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES OFF OF INDUSTRY
STANDARDS AND THAT THEY HAD
ALSO DONE AN ASSESSMENT
MEASURING THEMSELVES AGAINST
THOSE STANDARDS. AND IF YOU
TURN TO PAGE TEN OF THE REPORT.
YOU CAN SEE THAT TWENTY FOUR OF
THOSE ENTITIES RESPONDED THAT
THEY WERE ONLY PARTIALLY
COMPLIANCE. WITH THE STANDARDS
AND TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF SOME
OF THE AREASOF NON COMPLIANCE
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
FOUND DURING ASSESSMENTS WE
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE EXAMPLES IN
THE REPORT ONE ENTITY FOR
EXAMPLE. DIDN'T CHANGE THE
DEFAULT PASSWORDS ON CERTAIN I.
T. DEVICES WHICH- RAISES THE
REST THAT SOMEBODY THAT KNOWS
THE FALL PASSWORDS CAN
INTERPRET REAL ACCESS THOSE
DEVICES ANOTHER EXAMPLE WE
HIGHLIGHT IN THE REPORT IS AN
ENTITY WASN'T REGULARLY
APPLYING SECURITY UPDATES
MEANING THAT KNOWN
VULNERABILITIES PERSISTED IN
THE SYSTEM INCREASING THE RISK
THAT THOSE VULNERABILITIES
COULD BE EXPLOITED. SO THOSE
ARE SOME OF THE NON FINDINGS
THAT RIGHT AND IF I DURING
THESE ASSESSMENTS WE ALSO NOTE
THAT FOR ENTITIES HAD DONE AN
ASSESSMENT SO IT'S LIKELY THEY
HAVE WEAKNESSES THAT THEY'RE
JUST UNAWARE OF BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T DONE THE WORK TO
MEASURE THEMSELVES AGAINST
THOSE INDUSTRY BEST PRACTICES.
THAT ARE THAT ARE DOCUMENTED IN
THE STANDARDS. HOWEVER WE ALSO
NOTED THAT SOME OF THE ENTITIES
THAT WERE AWARE OF DEFICIENCIES
WEREN'T TAKING ADEQUATE STEPS
TO FOLLOW UP ON THOSE
DEFICIENCIES. FOR EXAMPLE ONE
ENTITY A WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT MILITARY AND DONE AN
INDEPENDENT SECURITY
ASSESSMENT. AND THE DEPARTMENT
MILITARY PROVIDED A REPORT
IDENTIFIED THE FIVE AREAS OF
THE GREATEST RISK TO THAT
ENTITY. AND THE SIXTEEN MONTHS
AFTER THIS ESTIMATE WE FOLLOWED
UP WITH THAT ENTITY AND THEY
HAD YET TO FULLYRESOLVE ANY OF
THOSE FIVE AREAS. IN FACT THEY
HAD NOT IDENTIFIED THE FULL
SCOPE OF WORK THEY NEED TO BE
DONE. THE TIME LINE FOR YOU FOR
DOING THAT WORK OR THE STAFFING
RESOURCES NEEDED TO FOR TO
FULLY RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE WAS AN ENTITY
THAT HAD DEFICIENCIES DATING
BACK TO TWENTY THIRTEEN. AND
WHEN WE FOLLOWED UP WITH THAT
ENTITY TO DETERMINE WHAT HOW
ARE YOU TRACKING. THESE
DEFICIENCIES THERE ONLY ABLE TO
PROVIDE US WITH POWER POINT
PRESENTATIONS THAT STAFF HAD
PROVIDED. TO THEIR I. T.
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE HOWEVER
THESE PRESENTATIONS WERE
MISSING KEY DETAILS SUCH AS
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR FIXING
THE PROBLEM. WHAT'S THE FULL
SCOPE OF WORK THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO TO FIX THAT PROBLEM
AND WHAT'S THE TIMELINE IN THE
TIME LINES IMPORTANT BECAUSE
SOME OF THESE ARE A TO SIX
YEARS OLD AND STILL NOT
RESOLVED. SO WE REALLY WERE
CONCERNED THAT NOT EVERYBODY
WAS ASSESSING THEMSELVES AND
THAT THERE ARE EVEN PEOPLE THAT
WERE HAD DEFICIENCIES THAT.
THAT WERE REMAINING OUTSTANDING.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT WE
THINK THERE'S OTHER LORD WE
BELIEVE THERE'S OTHER
DEFICIENCIES THAT AGENCIES ARE
JUST UNAWARE OF AND IF YOU TURN
TO PAGE THIRTEEN. YOU CAN SEE
THAT WE FOLLOWED UP WITH TEN
ENTITIES IN DETAIL. IN NINE OF
THE ENTITY SAID THAT THEY
FOLLOWED INDUSTRY STANDARDS
VERY COMMON LIKE EITHER THE
STATE STANDARDS THE FEDERAL
STANDARDS OR AN INTERNATIONAL
STANDARDS WE FOUND ALL THE
STANDARD TO BE VERY COMPARABLE
TO EACH OTHER. HOWEVER ONLY SIX
HAD FORMALLY ADOPTED THE
STANDARDS AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
FORMALLY ADOPT THE STANDARDS
BECAUSE THEY PROVIDE IT. A
REPEATABLE IT CONSISTENT WAY TO
ENSURE THAT YOU'RE PROTECTING
YOUR ASSETS IT'S BEST INDUSTRY
BEST PRACTICES. IN IT ALSO
PROVIDES AN AVENUE FOR YOU TO
EVALUATE YOURSELF OR FOR OTHER
ENTITIES THAT ARE YOU H. U.
AGAINST THOSE STANDARDS. IN IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE FOUND THAT
ONLY FOUR OF THE TEN ENTITIES
HAD FULLY ASSESS THEMSELVES
AGAINST THE STANDARDS MEANING
THE REMAINING ENTITIES. HAD
AREAS IN THEIR SECURITY
PRACTICES THAT THEY HADN'T
LOOKED AT SO THEY COULD HAVE
ADDITIONAL WEAKNESSES IN THESE
AREAS BUT THEY JUST HAD LOOKED
AT THOSE AREAS. AND THAT'S
HIGHLIGHTED BY ENTITY BE ENTITY
BE HAD DONE AND ASSESSMENTS
THAT LOOK AT OF A SUBSET OF
THEIR CONTROLS. AND WHEN WE ASK
THEM ABOUT WHY THEY DIDN'T LOOK
AT THE FULL SCOPE OF THEIR
STANDARDS. A RESPONSE THEY WENT
OUT AND FINISH THE ASSESSMENT
THEY DID A SUPPLEMENTAL
ASSESSMENT THAT LOOK AT THE
FULL SCOPE OF ALL THE CONTROLS.
WHEN THEY WERE DONE THEY REPORT
BACK TO US THAT THEY WERE ONLY
51% COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE
ADDITIONAL STANDARDS SO. THERE
WAS A LOT OF AREAS OF NON
COMPLIANCE THAT THEY JUST HAND
IDENTIFIED BECAUSE THEY HAD
LOOK VERY NARROWLY INITIALLY.
AND AS MS HOUSE SAID EARLIER
THESE FINDINGS ARE VERY SIMILAR
TARA TWENTY FIFTEEN. AUDIT
WHERE WE LOOK AT THE APARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY IN THE ENTITIES
UNDER ITS PURVIEW IN THAT AUDIT
NEARLY ALL SURVEY RESPONDENTS
SAID THAT THEY WERE NOT FULLY
COMPLIANT. AND THAT'S DESPITE
ABOUT HALF OF THEM PREVIOUSLY
REPORTING THAT APARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY THAT THEY WERE FULLY
COMPLIANT AND WHEN WE FOLLOWED
UP ON THAT DISCREPANCY WE WERE
TOLD THAT. THEY HAD USED A
CHECKLIST THEY ONLY CONTAIN
HIGH LEVEL LOOK AT A SUBSET OF
THE CONTROLS SO THEY WERE THEY
WERE HAVING THE SAME PROBLEM
WHERE THEY LOOK VERY NARROWLY
TO EVALUATE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WERE FULLY COMPLIANT. AND THEN
AS MISS HOW SAID. WE
RECOMMENDED A LOT OF
IMPROVEMENTS TO OVERSIGHT. AND
DOES IMPLEMENT OR THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED AND AS A RESULT IN
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE
CONCLUDED THAT THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY HAD IMPROVED ITS
OVERSIGHT IN THE COMPLIANCE OF
THE ENTITIES THAT IT OVERSEAS
HAD INCREASE SO THIS REALLY
HIGHLIGHTS THE FACT THAT
OVERSIGHT CAN HAVE. ON
COMPLIANCE. HOWEVER WHEN WE
LOOK AT NON REPORTING ENTITIES
THEY DON'T HAVE A SIMILAR
OVERSIGHT STRUCTURE MOST OF THE
ENTITIES. WE REVIEWED SAID THEY
DON'T HAVE AN OVERSIGHT
FRAMEWORK THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THEM TO ASSESS THEMSELVES
AGAINST. ANY INDUSTRY STANDARDS
COVER WE DID NOTE THAT. THREE
OF THE FOUR ENTITIES THAT HAD
FULLY ASSESS THEMSELVES DID
HAVE AN OVERSIGHT FRAMEWORK
THAT REQUIRED THOSE ASSESSMENTS
SO ONCE AGAIN HIGHLIGHTING THE
IMPACT OF. OF OVERSIGHT SO AS A
RESULT WE MADE THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE LEGISLATURE
SPECIFICALLY RECOMMENDED THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRE NON
REPORTING ENTITIES TO ADOPT A
FRAMER COMPARABLE TO ST FIFTY
THREE HUNDRED THE FRAMEWORK
MAINTAINED BY DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY. THAT THEY REGULARLY
MEASURE THEMSELVES AGAINST
THOSE STANDARDS. AT LEAST EVERY
THREE YEARS AND THEN THAT THEY
CONFIDENTIALLY CERTIFY
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE STANDARDS
TO LEGISLATURE AND IF NOT IF
APPLICABLE THAT THEY SUBMIT
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS. FOR
ANY OUTSTANDING DEFICIENCIES.
SO THAT'S AN OVERVIEW OF OUR
AUDIT AND WITH THAT I'LL TAKING
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AT THIS TIME ITSELF IN A FOR
SOME QUESTIONS MISTER COUNTY GO
AT. THANKS VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION FOR THE AUDIT SO
IF MY MEMORY SERVES ME
CORRECTLY WHENEVER WE TRIED TO
DO KIND OF ALONG THE LINES WE
RECOMMENDING THE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS GENERALLY SHOW UP AND
COMPLAIN ABOUT IT. SO I MY
QUESTION IS. THE FACT THAT
THESE ENTITIES ARE THAT ARE NOT
UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF THE
GOVERNOR ARE NOT REQUIRED FOR
REPORTER STATE LAW THAT'S A
CREATURE OF STATUTE I ASSUME
SO. I WATER THE CONSTITUTIONAL
LIMITS AS FAR AS BRINGING THOSE
ENTITIES UNDER THE SAME SORT OF
OVERSIGHT AND POLICIES AS THOSE
UNDER CONTROL THE GOVERNOR AND
THEN IF THERE ARE NO
CONSTITUTIONAL BARRIERS ARE
THERE ANY. REASONS POTENTIALLY
WHY THEY SHOULD NOT BE SUBJECT
TO THE SAME STANDARDS AND
PROTOCOLS. RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER KILEY I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE ARE SPECIFIC
CONSTITUTIONAL LIMITS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE CONCERN
THE CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS HAD
IN THE PAST WAS SOME OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT WAS PROPOSED
WAS TO HAVE THE CONSTITUTIONAL.
REPORT THE INFORMATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY WHICH
IS IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH SO
THEY HAD A CONCERN WITH RESPECT
TO THEIR INDEPENDENCE WE
BELIEVE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WE'VE MADE IN THIS REPORT
WHERE. THE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS AND OTHER ENTITIES
JUDICIAL BRANCH ENTITIES WOULD
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE SAID
SEPARATE BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
BUT THE LEGISLATURE HAS A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF OVERSIGHT
OVER THOSE PARTICULAR ENTITIES
BUT IT WOULD NOT. IT WOULD NOT
IN OUR VIEW CAUSE A PROBLEM
WITH RESPECT TO THE
INDEPENDENCE ISSUE THAT. THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RAISED IN THE
PAST. LOOKED AT LEGAL HERE
TODAY BUT I HAVE THEM LOOK AT
SOME STATUTORY PROVISIONS UNDER
THEY THE OPEN RECORDS ACT
LEGISLATIVE OPEN RECORDS ACT
AND THERE IS LANGUAGE IN THE
THAT ALLOWS THE LEGISLATURE TO
KEEP INFORMATION CONFIDENTIAL
AT PARTICULAR IF THERE'S A ALL
A SIMILAR LOSS SO MY ATTORNEYS
LOOKED AT THE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT AND THERE IS SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE IN THE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT THAT PROTECTS INFORMATION
SECURITY FROM DISCLOSURE SO
THAT CAN THAT CAN BE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO DISCLOSE THAT UNDER THE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT SO THE
LEGISLATURE DOES HAVE TAKEN
ISMS WITHIN. THE OPEN RECORDS
ACT TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT THIS
INFORMATION SO WE THINK THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE MADE IN
THE REPORT MAKES SENSE BECAUSE
THE REPORTS CAN GO TO THE
LEGISLATURE THE CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLANS CAN GO TO THE
LOVED LEGISLATURE AND THE
LEGISLATURE THROUGH THE TWO
COMMITTEES I'M HERE TODAY HEY.
WE SPECIFY ASSEMBLY PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION CYBER
SECURITY COULD ALSO BE INVOLVED
UP WOULD. HOW CONSTITUTIONAL AS
IN OTHER I ENTITIES ARE DOING
AND PROTECTING DATA AND
REMEDIATING ISSUES THAT ARE
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED. BUT
IN THEORY IF I WE WANTED ALL
THAT OTHER CONCERTS OFFICES
REPORT ADD TO THAT PART OF
TECHNOLOGY IT WOULD THERE BE
ANY CONSTITUTIONAL BARRIER THAT
OR THAT JUST BE VIEWED AS SORT
OF AN INFRINGEMENT ON THEIR
INDEPENDENCE YOU KNOW I DON'T
I'M NOT A LAWYER SO I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THERE WOULD
BE SPECIFIC CONSTITUTIONAL
ISSUES I DIDN'T I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH WHAT THEIR
ARGUMENTS WERE AT THE TIME. I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING IF THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTERESTED IN AND
PURSUING THAT AVENUE PERHAPS
WORK WITH LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL I
DON'T HAVE THE EXPERTISE TO.
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU
FOR. SEVEN I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS THIS IT DOES KIND OF
SEEM LIKE A RE RUN OF FOUR
YEARS AGO SO BUT HOPEFULLY WE
END UP WITH THE SAME KIND OF
OUTCOMES BECAUSE YOU KNOW I'VE
SAID MANY TIMES THAT SAID
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY REALLY
OF. STEPPED UP AND. SO F AYE
AYE WE PROBABLY CAN'T TALK
ABOUT BLANCA WHETHER THIS IS
ACCURATE OR NOT BUT DO YOU
THINK THAT THE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICES AND OTHER. THE OTHER
NON REPORTING ENTITIES HAVE
SUFFICIENT INFORMATION SECURITY
EXPERTISE IN THE CAPABILITY TO
OPERATE SEPARATELY OR
INDEPENDENTLY FROM THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH NOW I KNOW WE
CAN'T SAY ABOUT ALL OF THEM AND
YOU CAN'T CALL OUT CERTAIN
AGENCIES BUT CERTAINLY WE KNOW
THAT THAT DEPARTMENTS LIKE THE
AG AND SECRETARY OF STATE HAVE
TO MEET. HIGHER STANDARDS
THEMSELVES SO WE PRESUME THAT
THEY ARE. MOSTLY DOING WHAT
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO SOLVE. SO
I MEAN I MEAN YOU DON'T HAVE TO
SAY THAT BUT JUST IN GENERAL DO
YOU THINK THE EXPERTISE IS
THERE TO OPERATE INDEPENDENTLY
SO WE START A VARIETY OF
CIRCUMSTANCES AT THE DIFFERENT
ENTITIES WE WENT TO WE WENT TO
SOME ENTITIES THAT. SIR BUT
THEY WERE MOSTLY OR FULLY
COMPLIANT BASED FULLY ENTITIES
FULLY ASSESS THEMSELVES THEY
HAD OFFICIALLY ADOPTED
STANDARDS AND THEY HAD A VERY
ROBUST PROCESS WE HIGHLIGHT ONE
ENTITY IN THE REPORT THAT HAND
ADOPTED ANY STANDARDS AND THEY
RELIED SOLELY ON THE JUDGMENT
OF THEIR IT MANAGER. SO IS A
VERY LESS FORMAL PROCESS. LESS
ROBUST SO WE REALLY SAW A WIDE
RANGE WORKS SOME PEOPLE HAD. A
VERY COMPLETE PROCESS AND SOME
PEOPLE DIDN'T SO I'M NOT SURE
IF YOU THIS SERVICES DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY BUT HOW DID THE
INDEPENDENT SECURITY
ASSESSMENTS PERFORMED BY
OUTSIDE VENDORS COMPARED TO THE
SECURITY ASSESSMENTS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MILITARY. WE
DIDN'T SPECIFICALLY COMPARE
ASSESSMENTS DONE. ACROSS
DIFFERENT VENDORS. WE ARE
ACTUALLY LOOK TO SEE WHAT
ASSESSMENTS HAD THEY HAD AND
HOW MUCH OF THEIR STANDARDS
THAT THEY FOLLOW WE DID WE DO
NOTE THAT MANY ENTITIES DO USE
THE DEPARTMENT MILITARY FOR
THOSE THOSE ASSESSMENTS. IN DID
THOSE ARE GOOD ASSESSMENTS AND
THEY'RE VERY HELPFUL BUT
THEY'RE NOT COMPREHENSIVE BY
THEMSELVES SO. SO WE EXPECT
THEM TO DO ADDITIONAL
ASSESSMENTS ON TOP. YES AND I
MEAN ULTIMATELY YOU WANT TO BE
ABLE TO DO AN APPLES TO APPLES
MEMBERS AND EVEN IF YOU'RE
USING A OUTSIDE. OF VENDORS SO
ONE OF THE CONCERNS WE HAD WITH
THE BILL FROM LAST YEAR AND
THIS YEAR IS THAT. THERE WAS
SOME CONCERN ABOUT. THAT THE
STANDARDS MIGHT JEOPARDIZE THE
INDEPENDENCE OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICES IS THAT
A. I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYINGBUT WE DON'T SEE A
PROBLEM WITH I MEAN IT IT WOULD
BE EACH INDIVIDUAL ENTITY CAN
ADOPT STANDARDS AND AS MISTER
WARD INDICATED AS WE EXPLAIN IN
THE REPORT THERE'S
INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS THERE'S
THE SAM FIFTY THREE HUNDRED
THERE'S OTHER STANDARDS AND WE
DID A COMPARISON OF THOSE
STANDARDS TO SEE ARE THEY
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT AND AS
MISTER WARD INDICATED THEY'RE
RELATIVELY SIMILAR SO EACH OF
THE ENTITIES COULD ADOPT
STANDARDS. THAT THEY THINK
WORKS FOR THEIR PARTICULAR
AGENCY AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
I MEAN THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
CONTINUE THAT INDEPENDENCE AND
FOR THOSE ENTITIES THEN TO BE
REQUIRED TO ASSESS THEMSELVES
AGAINST STANDARDS THAT THEY
HAVE FORMALLY ADOPTED THAT WAS
ONE OF THE ISSUES IN THIS
REPORT THEY'RE THEY'RE
SUGGESTING THAT THEY'RE
FOLLOWING STANDARDS BUT THEY
HAVEN'T FORMALLY ADOPTED THEM
AND BASICALLY SAID KNOWN FOR
THAT AGENCY SAYING WE ARE GOING
TO COMPLY WITH ALL OF THESE
STANDARDS NEST OR WHATEVER IT
THE STANDARDS THEY CHOOSE TO
COMPLY WITH. THEN THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO ASSESS THEMSELVES
AGAINST THOSE STANDARDS AND
THEN AS WE RECOMMEND REPORT
THAT INFORMATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND CERTAINLY
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE DONE
A COMPREHENSIVE TEST IDENTIFIED
HIGH RISK DEFICIENCY IS GOING
TO BE A THING KNOWS AND HERE'S
OUR TIME FRAME SO I FROM OUR
VIEW WE DON'T THINK THERE IS A
PROBLEM WITH RESPECT DEPENDS IF
REPORTING TOTAL JUST LET RATHER
AND TO THE PARK TECHNOLOGY.
OKAY AND THEN OF I AM IN THAT
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY SO THE
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY HAVE DONE OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS MAJORITY OF
METRIC ABOUT. YOU KNOW FIFTEEN
ASSESSMENT AUDIT. DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY I DON'T HAVE THAT
KIND OF EXPERTISE SO YOUNG
POTENTIALLY AS A BEST PRACTICE.
THEY COULD THEY COULD PURSUE
THAT I THINK WHERE THEY ARE
RIGHT NOW THERE'S SO MANY THAT
AREN'T FULLY ASSESSING
THEMSELVES THEY DON'T KNOW
WHERE THEY ARE HOW COMPLIANT
THEY ARE. SO. FIRST THEY WOULD
HAVE TO SET A BASELINE AND THEN
MOVE FOR. SO OVER TIME IT
SOUNDS LIKE THEY WOULD BENEFIT
FROM IT BUT AS OF TODAY THEY
NEED TO ESTABLISH STANDARDS
ASSESS THEMSELVES
COMPREHENSIVELY SAID ROOM YOU
KNOW DEVELOP MITIGATION PLANS
AND THEN THE MATURITY MODEL AND
AGAIN I'M NOT THE EXPERT. THAT
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL IN THE
FUTURE. RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I'M JUST A COUPLE OF
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS IT ARE
THERE ANY ADVANTAGES. LET'S SAY
BETWEEN. UTILIZING THAT THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT WHEN IT
COMES TO ASSESSMENT VERSUS A
PRIVATE AND ENTITY OR A PRIVATE
VENDOR. YOU KNOW. DID YOU KNOW
OF WE DID NOT SPECIFICALLY LOOK
AT. THE QUALITY OF THE OF THE
REVIEWS WE WE'RE LOOKING TO
MAKE SURE DID YOU HAVE A REVIEW
WHAT DID YOU LOOK AT. ARE YOU
ADDRESSING DEFICIENCIES SO WE
DID NOT COMPARE PRIVATE VENDORS
VERSES MILITARY AND
METHODOLOGIES. SO IN YOUR VIEW
SO LONG AS THEY ARE IN
COMPLYING WITH ONE OF THE THREE
STANDARDS ARE AND THE- YOU KNOW
COULD POTENTIALLY BE IT
MAINTAIN THEIR INDEPENDENCE SO
TO SPEAK AND THEN REPORTING THE
RESULTS OR THE OUTCOME TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT SUFFICES AS
FAR AS THE AUDITOR'S.
ASSESSMENTS CONCERNS I'VE GONE
A CORRECTED. THAT'S CORRECT GOT
IT SO IN ANY JUST I WANNA I
DON'T WANT TO BELABOR THE POINT
BUT BUT THE THREE STANDARDS
THAT YOU MENTION SO THERE AS
FAR AS THE QUALITY OR OTHERWISE
THERE ARE COMPARABLE I THINK
THE VOICE EASE WITH COMPARABLE
IDEA A SIMILAR. AND WELL
THERE'S THE I. S. O. OR THE SAM
OR THE NEST STANDARDS TO THE
YOU KNOW ALL THREE CENTERS ARE
OKAY BYE BYE YOU FOLKS YES SO
ON PAGE FIVE WE LAY OUT THE
THREE MOST COMMON STANDARDS.
AND IT'S THE I SO THAN BUSINESS
AND SAM AND THERE'S A LOT OF
OVERLAP IN FACT SAM SAYS THAT
THE MINIMUM BASELINE SECURITY
IS NEST. SO THERE'S A LOT OF
OVERLAP A POINT AT EACH OTHER
AND THEN ON THE NEXT PAGE PAGE
SIX WE LAY OUT. AT A HIGH LEVEL
WHAT THE STANDARDS TYPICALLY
FOLLOW OR WOULD REQUIRE AND
THEY'RE ALL STRUCTURE
DIFFERENTLY BUT ADDRESS THE
SAME AREAS WHERE YOU HAVE TO
KNOW WHAT YOU NEED TO PROTECT
THEM WHAT LEVEL OF PROTECTION.
YOUR INFORMATION NEEDS GAP
IDENTIFIER ASKS THING YOU HAVE
TO PLAN TO PROTECT WHAT YOU
HAVE AGAINST THOSE RISK AND ALL
ALL OF THEM FOLLOW A VERY
SIMILAR PATTERN JUST THE
FORMATTING AND. THE LEVEL OF
DETAIL IS DIFFERENT. GOT IT.
OKAY I ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OKAY MYSTERY K. DO
THAT FOR EFFECTIVE OVERSIGHT
YOU NEED TO HAVE SOME SPECIFIC
A TECHNICAL EXPERTISE.
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE OBVIOUSLY
HELPS I THINK YOU SOME LEVEL OF
OVERSIGHT. BEYOND WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW IS HELPFUL BIG
SAMPLE WE POINT OUT WHERE AN
ENTITY HAS DEFICIENCIES DATING
BACK TO TWENTY THIRTEEN AND
THEY DON'T HAVE A PLAN. YOU
DON'T NEED TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
TO KNOW THAT THAT'S NOT A GOOD
SITUATION SO I THINK THERE'S
DEFINITELY SOME AREAS WHETHER
OR NOT ENTITIES ARE EVALUATING
THEMSELVES ARE NOT ARE THEY
COMPLAINTS ARE THEY NOT. THERE
SOME THINGS THAT DON'T NEED
SPECIAL THE TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
AS YOU GET INTO WHAT
DEFICIENCIES ARE AND WHAT'S
THEIR PLAN IS THAT A GOOD PLAN
IF YOU ADVANCE THE OVERSIGHT TO
THAT LEVEL THEN THERE WOULD
REQUIRE SOME LEVEL OF TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE. AND YOU HAD I MEAN
THE VIEW IT SUGGESTED THAT THAT
THE OVERSIGHT COULD BE CARRIED
OUT BY THE LEGISLATURE. AS
OPPOSED TO SEE TV SO IS THERE
DO YOU THINK THERE'S ENOUGH
EXPERTISE AND THE LEGISLATURE
TO THE FACT THAT THAT THAT.
WILL BUT I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE EXPERTISE
AND THE ABILITY TO HOLD THE
ENTITIES ACCOUNTABLE SOME OF
THOSE ENTITIES VIEWS MY OFFICE
FOR EXAMPLE. WE HAVE AYE
INTERNAL IT FOLKS WHO ARE
EXTREMELY TALENTED WE
CONTRACTED OUT TO HAVE OUR
ASSESSMENT DONE BECAUSE BEFORE
I WAS GONNA CRITICIZEANYBODY
ELSE I NEEDED TO KNOW. ARE WE
FULLY COMPLIANT. WITH CERTAIN
STANDARDS AND WE WERE NOT AND
WE NEED TO TIGHTEN UP CERTAIN
THINGS SO WE HIRED THE
EXPERTISE TO ASSIST US AND
DIRECTING US HERE. HERE'S YOUR
ASSESSMENT HERE THE WEAKNESSES
THAT WERE IDENTIFIED THIS IS
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO TO FIX IT
BUT I HAD INTERNAL FOLKS ABLE
TO DO THOSE TORT TYPES OF
THINGS AND- ESTABLISH THE- AS
AS- MISTER WARD INDICATED. DO
WE HAVE A PLAN. WHERE WE'RE
GONNA DRESS THE HIGH RISK
DEFICIENCIES IF WE HAD ANY WHAT
IS OUR APPROACH AND WHAT'S THE
TIME FRAME FOR FIXING THAT SO
THE LEGISLATURE CERTAINLY HAS
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF OVERSIGHT AS
FAR AS- HAVE YOU HAD AN
ASSESSMENT DONE. HAVE YOU
IDENTIFIED THOSE WEAKNESSES
WHEN OUR YOU'RE GOING TO
CORRECT THEM WHICH ONES ARE
HIGH RISK THOSE TYPES OF THINGS
AND THOSE. KEYS MAY THAT MAY
HAVE THE IN HOUSE EXPERTISE AS
MISTER WARD SAID. DEPEND ON THE
SIZE OF THE NCS SOME OF THE-
CONSTITUTIONAL IN PARTICULAR
MAY HAVE THAT EXPERTISE IN
HOUSE. BUT IF THEY DON'T THEY
THEY CONTRACT BUT FOR THAT.
TIME NOW FOR THEM TO DO THAT.
ALSO CONDUCTED ACOSTA ANNOUNCES
OR COST ON COMPARISON BETWEEN
LET'S SAY ON THE ONE HAND. OF
THE NON REPORTING AGENCIES
DOING THEIR OWN ASSESSMENTS
VERSUS. OUR THE LET'S SAY THE
CD T. PERFORMING MOST OF THE
ASSESSMENTS WAS HER COME
COMPARISON BETWEEN THE TWO.
WELL WE DIDN'T DO THAT TYPE OF
ANALYSIS. OKAY IF THERE ARE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SO I WANT TO THANK OF THE
PANELISTS FOR JOINING US HERE
TODAY IF YOU COULD STAY A
LITTLE BIT LONGER SO THAT MIGHT
BE QUESTIONS THAT TAMI RYSSA.
SO I THANK YOU AND LET'S BRING
UP A SECOND PANEL. REPRESENTING
THE SECOND PANEL WE HAVE ANY
THàNH WHO IS THE DIRECTOR AND
STATE CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER. HAS WELL AS SOME
METALLIC. A TALLY T. PENICHE
ARE ACTING STATE. CHIEF
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICER SO
FEEL FREE TO CORRECT MY
PRONUNCIATION. ALSO I WON THE
THIS IS THE NOTED GERMAN SO. I
WANT TO WELCOME YOU AND FEEL
FREE TO INTRODUCE OURSELVES
PLEASE HI I'M AMANDA BULLOCK
CHIEF OF POLICIES PROJECT
PLANNING FOR DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY. THANK YOU WELCOME
THANKS CHAIR ONE CHURCH I'LL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCHFOR HAVINGUS
OVER I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS. AND FOR THE RECORD
MY NAME IS VITALI PENICHE
ACTING STATE CHIEF INFORMATION
SECURITY OFFICER. THANK YOU AND
WELCOME AND THAT CHAIR A MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
INVITING DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
I'M AMY THàNH DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND
I'M HERE HAPPY TO THIS ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONVERSATION YOU
LIKE TO HAVE IN RESPONSE TO
SPECIFICALLY THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT. NUMBER PRIOR TO JUMPING
TO THAT IF I MAY TAKE JUST A
COUPLE MINUTES TO PERHAPS LAY
OUT A CONTACT'S CONVERSATION
LITTLE BIT OF A HISTORY
ESPECIALLY I HEARD THERE'S
QUITE A BIT OF A MISSION
COMPARING TO ON THE AUDIT
REPORT THAT WAS CONDUCTED BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN RE
RELEASE IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
AND THE EFFORT THAT WAS IN
PLACE. SINCE THEN. SO A LITTLE
BIT OF A BACKGROUND I YOU DOES
IT HAVE THE I WAS APPOINTED IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN BY. A
FORMER ADMINISTRATION GOVERNOR
BROWN TO THIS PARTICULAR ROLE
ONE OF THE TOP PRIORITY WHEN I
CAME IN IT WAS SPECIFICALLY ON
CYBERSECURITY. AND THAT WAS
ALSO AROUND THE TIME THAT I
DOUBT EXECUTIVE ORDER NOW IT'S
BY STATUTE DEKSTOP WHICH MEN OF
CALIFORNIA. AS CYBERSECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER. AND WITHOUT
EXTRAPOLATION MEN OF FOR
PRINCIPLE DEPARTMENTS TO
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
MILITARY CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL IN CALIFORNIA. OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES ALONG WITH
MY DEPARTMENT DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY WE CALL OURSELF THE
CORE FOR. ARE THE MAIN
PRINCIPLES OF THE CYBERSECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER. JOINING AT
THE HEARING TODAY WE HAVE THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE CORE FOR
SITTING THE FIRST ROLE. SO THAT
IF THERE'S EVER A NEED I NEED A
PHONE A FRIEND I CAN TURN
AROUND AND- THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
STEP UP AND HELP OUT. AND THEIR
ATTENDANCE TODAY ISVERY
SIGNIFICANT TO ALSO DEMONSTRATE
THAT WHEN HE COMES TO
CYBERSECURITY. ITS ONE TEAM ONE
FIGHT. AND EVEN THOUGH I
APPRECIATE THE AUDITOR'S
RECOGNITION AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S RECOGNITION THAT
SINCE THE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
AUDIT DODD A DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY ALONG WITH THE HELP
WITH OUR PARTNERS IN CAL SICK.
HAVE MADE BY PROGRESS. TOWARDS
THE PRODUCTION BETTER
PROTECTION OF THE STATE. I CAN
SAFELY SAY WERE ONLY SCRATCH
THE SURFACE. AND WE ALWAYS HAVE
THIS MODEL THAT IS NOT A MATTER
OF IF THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT CYBERSECURITY
RELATED INCIDENT IS MATTER OF
WHEN. SO BECAUSE OF THAT THAT
WE REMAIN VERY VIGILANT AND YOU
KNOW CORPS NAY BEING PRO ACTIVE
PARTNERS THAT ARE GOING BEYOND
THE BOUNDARY OF STATE ENTITIES.
WITH CAL SAKE AND AS WELL AS
WITH OUR CONNECTION WITH THE
LOCALS WE CONSTANTLY TALK TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES IN THEIR
PRODUCTION WHEN IT COMES TO
DATA AS WELL AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS THE
PUBLIC SECTOR. BECAUSE ONE
FUNDAMENTAL KEY THAT WE ON TO
EMPHASIZE WHEN HE COMES THROUGH
CYBERSECURITY DATA SHARING
INFORMATION SHARING IS WITHOUT
THE BOUNDARY. WITHOUT THE
BOUNDARY OF WHO YOU'RE
REPORTING TO WITHOUT THE
BOUNDARY OF WHAT TO
ORGANIZATION CHARTS SPEAK TO
INFORMATION FREE FLOWS AND
THAT'S WHERE ALSO BECOMES THE
BOND ABILITY WHEN IT COMES TO
CYBERSECURITY MEASURE. SO WITH
THAT. THE MINUTE IF THE COUPLE
MORE POINTS ON THAT IN ADDITION
TO THE EXTRAPOLATION MEN OF CAL
SICK THERE WAS A I I'VE HEARD A
LOT OF QUESTIONS EARLY ABOUT
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF OVERSIGHT
I'M I WANTED TO PERHAPS OUT OF
CONTEXT THAT WHEN HE COMES TO
THE U. RESPONSIBILITY TO
OVERSIGHT THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY HIGHS IT'S MORE THAN
THE FACT OF MAKING SURE THAT
THE DEPARTMENT HAVE COMPLIANCY
OR SELF REPORTED COMPLIANCE
STATE. AS ONE OF THE FINDING
THAT WAS FOUND BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX THIRTEEN AND WE
HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY ADDRESSING
IS NOT ENOUGH FOR THIS ENTITY
THEMSELVES TO SELF SAID I'M
COMPLIANT. IT IS THE CONTINUED
JOURNEY IN HELPING THEM NOT
ONLY TO SAY YOURSELF COMPLIANT
BUT LEFT HAS FOR YOU ARE YOU
MEETING THOSE COMPLIANCY AND IF
YOU'RE NOT LET'S HELP YOU TO
CONTINUE TO MATURE AND THAT'S
WHY THE ROUGH FRIENDS THE
MATURE THE METRICS AND THEN AND
THEN IF YOU STATE YOUR MAKE
PROGRESS GREAT ON THOSE PIRATES
ENTITY LET'S CONDUCT ADDITIONAL
AUDIT WHICH IS THE RISK
BELIEVE. IN TECHNOLOGY SO THAT
WE COULD HELP YOU TO ASSURE
THAT FROM A POLICY MORE WE
STAND FOR COMPARISON AS WELL AS
IF PRACTICAL. IMPLEMENT XIN
JUST TEN OF THE. AND IS READY
ASSESSMENT CONDUCTED BY
MILITARY. IS THIS WHAT WE CALL
IT WE ACTUALLY HAVE A DIAGRAM
THAT SHOWS A CYCLE OF FROM MY
END YOU COMPLIANCE SELF OF
REPORTING. TO A BI ANNUAL
INDEPENDENT A SECURITY
ASSESSMENT DIED OF A MILITARY
CONDUCT OR A THIRD PARTY TO A-
TRY ANNUAL AND NOW WE ACTUALLY
BECOMES MORE OF A THREE TO FOUR
YEAR TYPE OF AUDIT. AS WELL AS
THE CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT
MONITORING WHERE THEY ARE A
MATURING THEIR SECURITY
MEASURE. ON TOP OF DIED EVERY
INCIDENT THAT HAPPENED IN THE
STATE OR IN GOVERNMENT IN
GENERAL IT'S ALSO A INFORMATION
AND LEARNING EXPERIENCE SO FROM
THERE IS MIGHT NOT MATTER OF
SIMPLY SINGLE INCIDENT HAPPENED
LET'S JUST GO AHEAD AND WE
MEET. HEY BUT WHAT DID WE LEARN
FROM THAT INCIDENT HOW DO WE RE
MEDIA FROM IT BECOMES A
POWERFUL KNOWLEDGE SHARING AS
WELL AS INTELLIGENCE SHARING
THAT WE PROVIDE. AS AS THIS
BROADER UMBRELLA OF THE
OVERSIGHT AND DIED IT'S REALLY
THE MISSION OF ON THE CAL SICK
AS WELL AS. PARTICIPATION A
CORE FOR WHEN IT COMES TO
CYBERSCURITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GERMAN ANYTHING TO ADD. I
YEAH I WILL HAVE WILL
DEFINITELY I'LL JUST TO
REITERATE THE POINT CYBER
SECURITY IS TRULY A TEAM SPORT
AND NEEDS TO BE A TEAM SPORT
THERE ARE MANY MANY ADVERSARIES
OUT THERE IN THE WORLD THE
TACKING US TWENTY FOUR BY SEVEN
AROUND THE CLOCK. IN THE NEED
TO GET LUCK YOU'RE RIGHT ONCE
ONLY WHILE ONLY ONCE US AS THE
GOOD GUYS THE DEFENDERS WE NEED
TO BE RIGHT A 100% OF THE TIME
ALL THE TIME AND WE CAN'T DO IT
ALONE AND JUST AN ISLAND OR IN
ONE DEPARTMENT OR ONE AGENCY.
ALSO THAT'S WHY WE'VE BEEN
TOGETHER AS A QUORUM FOR TO
REALLY UNIFIER BECAUSE WHERE WE
TRULY CANNOT PRACTICE THIS US
SPORT ALONE JUST LIKE. AMY AMY
REFERRED TO AS ONE TEAM ONE
FIGHT SO I DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE THE BANDING TOGETHER
OF DEPARTMENTS AND KIND OF
PUSHING THE MISSION OF MATURING
SECURITY AND WITHIN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND WHEN WE DO
THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS
WE DO THROUGH OUR GOVERNANCE
AND OVERSIGHT ONE OF THE THINGS
AMY REFER TO IS THE TRAINING
AND THE GUIDANCE WE PROVIDE SO
WE DO COLLECT A LOT OF
INTELLIGENCE A LOT OF DATA FROM
FROM OUR DEPARTMENTS IN THE
FORM OF AUDITS ASSESSMENT. WEEK
GOALIE THAT DATA AND ARE ABLE
TO PROVIDE MORE RELEVANT
RELEVANT POLICIES AND GUIDANCE
TO DEPARTMENT SO THAT THEY THEY
CAN MATURE AND SOLVE THE RIGHT
THINGS. AT THE RIGHT TIME FOR
THE RIGHT PRICE TO BECAUSE IF
WE CAN'T OVER INVEST OR UNDER
VESTED SECURITY WE REALLY NEED
TO. FIND THE RIGHT BALANCE AND
WE REALLY ARE ABLE TO ACHIEVE
THAT USING KIND OF THIS
OVERSIGHT CYCLE THAT WE HAVE
BEEN PRACTICING OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS. SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
CAN A CONTINUING TO BUILD OUT
THERE AND THERE ARE DEFINITELY.
THINGS WE COULD DO A LITTLE BIT
BETTER BASED ON PRE PRIOR
LESSONS LEARNED IDEALLY I'D
LIKE TO PRACTICE AND AUDIT AN
ASSESSMENT PRACTICE
CONTINUOUSLY SO THAT WE'RE NOT
KINDA DOING THAT ARE AT A POINT
IN TIME BALANCE. BECAUSE WE
TRULY NEED TO BE FASTER THAN
THE ADVERSARIES TO THE
ATTACKERS THE THAT WERE ARE
OFTEN TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OUT. TO ON. YOUR CANAL.
VERY GOOD SO WITH THAT LIKE TO
OPEN IN A FOR A COMMON QUESTION
MISTER KILEY GUY. GOOD
AFTERNOON TRUCK TONKA. DOES
YOUR DEPARTMENT INTERFACE AT
ALL WITH THE NON REPORTING
AGENCIES IN ANYWAY YES WE
ACTUALLY DO AND ALSO TO ALSO
ADD ADDITIONAL CONTEXT TO THAT.
THE AUDITOR REPORT AS IN NON
REPORTING AGENCY IN IN OUR
DEFINITION WHEN HE COMES FOR
NOT REPORTING AGENCY IT
ACTUALLY GOES BEYOND ON THE
CONSTITUTION OFFICE WE ALSO
HAVE INDEPENDENT ENTITIES THAT
ARE WITHIN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
THAT ARE WORKING IT YOU KNOW AT
THAT NOT UNDER THE DIRECT
SUPERVISION IF YOU WERE BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. BUT IS PART
OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AS WELL
AS OF COURSE YOU KNOW JUDICIAL
BRANCH ANOTHER BRANCH YOU KNOW
AS MISSION SO I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN WE SAID AND NINE
REPORTING AGENCY WE DO HAVE
DIFFERENT SCENARIO WHEN IT
COMES TO CONSTITUTIONAL VERSUS
NON CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICE. SO
HOW DO YOU INTERFACE WITH THOSE
ENTITIES THAT ARE CONSIDERED
NON REPORTING. SO WE INTERFACE
WITH THEM IN SEVERAL ASPECT IN
IN FACT I WOULD ASK I'M IMPAIR
ACHIEVE A POLICY TO CHIMING AT
CC FIT AS WELL. THAT IN TO DATE
WHEN IT COMES TO TECHNOLOGY
OVERSIGHT JUST AS OUR SISTER
DEPARTMENT WHAT A AS THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. YOU KNOW
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES AND
DEPARTMENT HR WE DO HAVE
BUSINESS OPERATION TYPE OF
OVERSIGHT. YOU KNOW WITH THOSE
ENTITY WE PROVIDE OUR
INTERACTION WITH THE
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICE IN MANY
CASES IS THE PROJECT OVERSIGHT.
SO WHEN THERE'S A TECHNOLOGY
PROJECT A CERTAIN THRESHOLD
THAT REQUIRES FINDING YOU KNOW
TO LEGISLATURE WE PROVIDE THAT
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY. TO
THEM AS WELL AS OTHER BUSINESS
FUNCTION A CHECK SUCH AS YOU
KNOW HR AND PROCUREMENT WE DO
THAT AS WELL. SO I DON'T KNOW
IF ANYTHING I YEAH JUST GO
ALONG THE LINES ABSENT ACIDITY
IS THERE CONTROL AGENCY SIMILAR
TO. THE OTHER CONTROL AGENCIES
WE DO. ADMINISTERED SIMILAR
PROGRAMS AND JUST LIKE H. R.
PROCUREMENT CDT DOES TO PROVIDE
A PUBLIC OVERSIGHT. TO OTHER
ENTITIES WITHIN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH AS WELL AND THEN. THOSE
STANDARDS THAT WE DO APPLY ARE
ALL CONSISTENTLY PUT INTO A
STANDARD THE STATE.
ADMINISTRATIVE MANUAL AND SO
DOES STANDARDS ALSO COVER IN
ADDITION IT AND SECURITY THEY
COVER PROCUREMENT. AS WELL AS
HR POLICIES AS WELL. SO THERE'S
ALREADY THAT LEVEL OR SAY
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH SIMPLY
HAVING ALL. ENTITIES ABIDE BY
THE SAME INFORMATION SECURITY
STANDARD AND BE SUBJECT YEAR
OVERSIGHT AND TURN TERMS OF
COMPLIANCE DO YOU THINK THAT IF
WE WERE TO DO THAT THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY IMPROVE OUR-
INFORMATION SECURITY SITUATION.
I WOULD I WOULD DEFINITELY SAID
DIED DEPENDING ON WHAT ORDER
CONSTITUTIONAL PROBABLY HAVE A
DIFFERENT AREA OF THE CONCERNS
VERSUS INDEPENDENT ENTITIES OR
ANOTHER BRANCH. I WOULD DEFER
TO THOSE CONCERNED FOR THEM TO
SPEAK TO HOWEVER I DO WANT TO
CLARIFY DIED EARLIER WHEN THERE
WAS DISCUSSION. ABOUT THIS AND
SPECIFICALLY ON THE YOU KNOW
WHAT DO YOU NEED TO DO TO
IMPROVE THE STATE WIDE SECURITY
MEASURE. IS DEFINITELY NOT OUR
INTENTION AT ALL TO HAVE ANY
INTERFERENCE OR IN PEAK INTO
WHAT I CALL THE MAIN LINES OF
BUSINESS OF THOSE INDIVIDUAL
DEPARTMENTS. THE SECURITY
MEASURE SIMILAR TO WHEN IT
COMES TO PROJECTS TO HR WE SEE
IT AS ME THAT ONE OF THE
BUSINESS OPERATION. AND THAT'S
WHERE WE LIKE TO SEE TO HAVE
CONSISTENCY WHEN IT COMES TO
MEASUREMENT AND OVERSIGHT.
RIGHT SO IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
YOU KNOW SUBSECTORS ALASTOR IN
THE WORLD WHERE WE WANT TO HAVE
OF FRAGMENTATION. IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND SO THE
DISTINCTION YOU JUST RECEIVED
TO MAKE SENSE I MEAN IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT IF EXECUTIVE THE
INDEPENDENCE OF. EACH OF THE
EXECUTIVE OR EVEN THE
INDEPENDENT EXECUTIVE AGENCIES
A SOMETHING THAT'S- IMPORTANT
YOU KNOW AS COMPLIANCE WITH AN
INFORMATION SECURITY STANDARD
AS A MINISTERIAL FUNCTION
ESSENTIALLY I MEAN MAYBE YOU
KNOW. THAT THAT'S NOT A POLICY
MAKING FUNCTION AND SO I THE
CONCERNS ABOUT INDEPENDENT SEEM
A LITTLE. AS UNFOUNDED TO ME
AND IF THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE REALLY CARE ABOUT I MEAN ARE
THERE OTHER SOLUTIONS COULD WE
MAKE YOUR DEPARTMENT SOMEHOW AN
INDEPENDENT. DEPARTMENT SO THEN
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE THIS CONCERN
ABOUT OTHER EXECUTIVE OFFICES
HAVEN'T REPORT TO SOMETHING
THAT'S UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR. WATER THAT WHAT WOULD
BE THE BEST WAY TO HAVE A MORE
UNIFIED APPROACH. I WOULDN'T
VENTURE OUT TO SAID I HAVE
ANSWER FOR THAT THE BUT I THINK
THIS IS WHY WERE. HERE HAVING A
CONVERSATION AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE INPUT AND IDEAS
YOU KNOW BY THE AUDITOR'S. I
THINK I BELIEVE THE ANGLE IS
THE SAME AND- IN ALL FAIRNESS
ALL THE INDEPENDENT ENTITY THAT
WE HAVE TALKED TO THEY HAVE THE
SAME. SIMILAR ANGLE IT IS THAT
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO WORK
TOGETHER. TO ACHIEVE THE HIGHER
LEVEL OF CYBER SECURITY
PROTECTION. I THINK IS WOULD IT
NEEDS TO HAVE A GOOD OPEN
DIALOGUE ABOUT. HOW TO GET
THERE AND PERHAPS OR OPTIONS AT
THE TABLE. THANK YOU. SEVEN
DIED WHEN YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT YOU DO COLLABORATOR READY
WITH THE CONSTITUTIONAL AS AND
OTHER NON REPORTING AGENCIES
BUT YOU WEREN'T REALLY
SPECIFICALLY TALKING ABOUT
INFORMATION SECURITY YOU'RE NOT
A USER COLLABORATION IN THAT
AREA SOLD IT LET ME MAKE SURE
I'VE I UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION
INFORMATION SECURITY TO DATE WE
DO NOT HAVE PER VIEW AS THE YOU
KNOW THE AUDITOR'S REPORT HAVE
A DEFINED INTO WITH THE
SECURITY PRACTICE OF THOSE
INDEPENDENCE HOWEVER THERE ARE
SOME INDEPENDENCE AND TWO TEETH
ARE VOLUNTARILY COMPLIANT AND
HAVE BEEN VERY COLLABORATIVE
AND- YOU KNOW WORKING WITH US
ON THAT. AND LIVES LET'S SAY
SPECIFICALLY I KNOW YOU THESE
THREAT ASSESSMENTS THAT YOU
PASS OUT TO ALL THE YOU KNOW
THE DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS ARE
YOU SHARING THAT THREAT
ANALYSIS WITH THE
CONSTITUTIONAL IS ANOTHER NON
REPORTING AGENCIES. YOU'VE ANY
AGENCY THAT HAVE ASK FOR THOSE
INFORMATION OR HAVE REACH OUT
TO NOT ONLY DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY BURKE. BUT WITH CAL
SICK AS WELL WHICH WERE PART OF
WERE OPENLY SHARING THOSE
INFORMATION AND IS THAT A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION THAT HAVE
ASKED TO SEE THIS I MEAN THE
THREAT INFORMATION SEEMS LIKE
IT COULD BE QUITE. VALUABLE IF
YOU KNOW. YOU KNOW THAT THERE'S
A CERTAIN. SO ISN'T AS AN
IRISH. YEAH THIS IS AN EXAMPLE
YEAH THERE ARE CERTAIN ENTITIES
THAT DO VOLUNTARILY PARTICIPATE
IN IN OUR OVERSIGHT BUT DO IT
TO A DEGREE NOT FULLY. AS THAT
EXAMPLE THEY DO PROVIDE THEIR
CONTACT INFORMATION VIA OUR
DESIGNATION LETTERS. AND WE DO
LEVERAGE THAT CONTACT
INFORMATION TO DISSEMINATE AND
BROADCAST OUT THREAT
INFORMATION. AND ADDITIONALLY
THERE ARE CERTAIN I ESOS THAT
DO COME TO OUR- MEETINGS AND
TRAININGS AND BRIEFINGS. WE
ALSO BROADCAST AND DISSEMINATE
SOME THREAT INFORMATION THERE
AND IN ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO SIGN
UP ON SOME OF OUR MAILING LISTS
ON. INCLUDING THINGS LIKE MSI
SACK. WHICH IS A REALLY A GREAT
SOURCE OF INFORMATION FOR
PROTECTION AND DEFENSE. HI I
GET THAT I'M I'M AND YOU'RE
SAYING SOME OF THEM BUT I'M
JUST SAYING IS THAT. A
SIGNIFICANT LIKE WHAT PERCENT.
OF ALL THESE NON REPORTING
AGENCIES ARE WORKING AT LEAST
COLLABORATIVELY WITH YOU ON
THAT. ARE GETTING A THREAT
INFORMATION RIGHT I THINK FROM
INFORMATION SHARING WHICH IS A
ONE WAY COMMUNICATION AND JUST
WERE WERE BEING VERY OPEN ABOUT
IT THAT. IT'S ALMOST LIKE
WHOEVER IS WILLING TO SIGN UP
TO OUR YOU KNOW DISTRIBUTION
MAILING LIST. THEY THEY COME
AND WE AND WE INVITE THOSE
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICER IN
THE DEPARTMENT TO JOIN OUR
REGULAR MEETINGS. PERCENTAGE
WISE I DON'T KNOW IF WE KNOW
THAT WITH OUR HEAD I WOULDN'T
KNOW THAT OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD WE WOULD HAVE TO REFER TO
OUR INTERNAL KIND OF DATABASE
THAT WE COLLATE THAT
INFORMATION IN. THAT BUT I
WOULD SAY IS INCONSISTENT. IT
SOMETIMES IS DEPENDING ON THE
NEED OR AT ON AT HAWK BASIS. BY
DUBBED THE INFORMATION SHARING
AND STUFF AND ONLY HAS BEEN.
YOU KNOW. QUITE OPEN. OKAY AND
THEN I ALSO HAD ASK THE AUDITOR
ABOUT WHETHER THERE. AND
EFFECTIVE OVERSIGHT REQUIRES
SPECIFIC TECHNICAL EXPERTISE I
WAS WONDERING IF YOU COULD ADD
ANYTHING TO WHAT SHE SAID.
PARDON DO YOU WANT TO ADD ANY.
I'D I'D BUT BE HAPPY TO AYE I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT WHEN HE
COMES TO IT REALLY SAID THE
DEFINITION OF OVERSIGHT RAY
FROM ANYWHERE TO MAKING SURE
SOMEBODY AS A REPORTING THAT
THERE ARE COMPLIANT AND THIS
AUDITOR'S HAVE POINTED OUT THAT
LEVEL OVERSIGHT YOU PROBABLY DO
NOT NEED A- YOU KNOW SECURITY
IT TECHNICAL SKILL IT SAID
OTHER THAN SAY YEP YOUR WE WERE
REPORTING YES WE'RE STUFF
COMPLIANT. BUT IF YOU WANT TO
GO DEEPER TO REALLY ASSESS WHAT
THEY'RE REPORTING IS SELF
REPORTING IS CORRECT OR MORE
IMPORTANTLY OUR GOAL OF OUR
OVERSIGHT CYCLE IS NOT TO POINT
THEM WHAT THEY DID NOT DO BUT
HELP THEM TO GET BETTER AND
THAT HELP THEM TO GET BETTER
THROUGH TRAINING ADVISORY
SERVICE OR EVEN WHEN THEY SAY
HEY WE THINK WE DO THIS BUT
WHEN WE ASSESS THEY REALLY
DIDN'T. WE'RE GOING TO HELP
THEM TO SAY THIS IS WHAT YOU
NEED TO DO TO REACH THE NEXT
LEVEL OF COMPLIANCE AND THAT
LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT IN MY
OPINION WE REALLY BENEFIT FROM
A TECHNICAL EXPERTISE. AND JUST
OUT TO THAT IF I MAY SOUND.
COMPLIANCE ALONE DOES NOT EQUAL
SECURITY COMPLIANCE ALONE SO
IT'S A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD A
BASS LINE IF YOU WILL THAT
THAT'S CONSISTENT ACROSS THE
BOARD AND IT SHOULD BE
CONSISTENT THAT'S KIND OF WHY
WHY WE'RE ALL HERE TODAY IS TO
KIND OF. SET THAT CONSISTENCY
ACROSS JURISDICTIONAL
BOUNDARIES. BUT THEN WE NEED TO
GO FURTHER BEYOND COMPLIANCE
HOW DO WE MEASURE OUR
COMPLIANCE HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
IT'S EFFECTIVE IT'S STAYING UP
TO DATE. SO THAT'S WHAT WE ALSO
TRY TO ENFORCE AND DO WITH SOME
OF OUR- MILITARY DEPARTMENT
INFORMATION SECURITY
ASSESSMENTS ARE INDEPENDENT
SECURITY ASSESSMENTS IT'S
REALLY TO MEASURE. THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE CONTROLS
WERE WERE IN FORCING AND
OUTLINING FOR THE DEPARTMENTS.
AND REALLY THE GOAL IS TO
ENFORCE IT AND CONDUCT OUR
PRACTICE WITH THE UNIFIED WANT
ONE MEASURING STICK THAT'S
THAT'S CONSISTENT. DO THINK
THAT ADOPTING ONE STANDARD OVER
THE OTHER WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACT THE SECURITY AT THE
STATE. THE QUESTION OF A LIKE A
TOP IN ONE OF THE THREE
STANDARDS OR THE OTHER OR
HAVING A CONSISTENT STANDARD
WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHT ON THE-
THE DIFFERENT STANDARDS AND THE
NEEDS OF TO BE STANDARD YEAH.
OF ALL HAVE A TELL YOU CHIME IN
I KNOW HIS OF BEEN WANTING TO
SPEAK TO RALPH IF I I'LL I'LL
ACT ABRUPT BROADLY. THE I SO
STANDARD FOR EXAMPLE THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE UNIVERSAL MORE
GENERIC IT'S SUPPLY TYPICALLY
GLOBALLY IT'S ACTUALLY RAN BY
THE BY AN NGO HEADQUARTERED AND
SWITZERLAND FROM THE MISTAKEN.
SO WE'VE ADOPTED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN THIS STATE
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE WHICH IS
THE CURRENT REVISION FOR AND WE
LEVERAGE SOME OF THE SECURITY
CONTROLS AND SECURITY DOMAINS
WITHIN OUR SAM FIFTY THREE
HUNDRED SO IT'S REALLY SIMILAR
AND THEY THEY REALLY CORRELATE
TO EACH OTHER. BUT THEN THE
NEXT EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
IS A SUPERSET IF YOU WILL. OF
THE I. SO TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
OR TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND TWO
STANDARD SO THEY'RE A LITTLE
BIT MORE SPECIFIC FOR MORE
SPECIFIC SPECIFICITY THAT'S
BECAUSE THE I SO STANDARDS A
LITTLE BIT MORE IT HAS TO BE
UNIVERSAL BECAUSE IT IT DOES
APPLY GLOBALLY SO IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY COVER EVERYTHING.
SO WHICH IS WHY WE CHOSE TO
APPLY THE NATIONAL FEDERAL A
FRAMEWORK AND WITH IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WHAT Y. WEEK
MAP THAT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. RAYMOUR BUT WE CAN.
ADD OR REDUCE TO IT THAT WAY WE
CAN ADD MORE SPECIFICITY TO
CERTAIN CONTROLS IN THE MORE
PRESCRIPTIVE. VERSUS SUBJECTIVE
BECAUSE SOME OF THESE CONTROLS
CAN BE APPLIED DIFFERENTLY
WHETHER YOU'RE DOING BUSINESS.
LOCALLY AND ON PREMISES WITHIN
THE PHYSICAL DATA CENTER OR IN
THE CLOUD OR OR VARIOUS OTHER
EXAMPLES THAT WE GET A LITTLE
BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS
OF GUIDING OUR- ENTITIES THAT
WE OVERSEE INTO. HOW YOU SHOULD
DEPLOY A PARTICULAR STANDARD.
RIGHT SO IT YOU KNOW TO ADD ON
WHAT BATALI SAME BASICALLY OUR
PREFERENCE IS TO HAVE ONE SET
OF STANDARDS. AND THE REASON IS
AGAIN YOU KNOW ADOPTING ONCE
AND SETS OF STANDARDS NOT ONLY
SOLELY FOR THE FACT THAT
SOMEBODY CHECK OFF THE BOX YES
I'M GONNA USE THAT FOR MY
COMPLIANCE MEASUREMENT. BUT
REALLY TO THROUGH THAT ONE SET
OF STANDARDS WHEN YOU COME TO A
COMMUNITY OF PRACTICE WORKING
WITH THOSE ALREADY IN A LIMITED
TECHNICAL RESOURCE. RESOURCES
TO HELP RELIEVE EACH OF THE
ENTITY TO MATURE IN ACHIEVING
THOSE STANDARDS DO BETTER WITH
IT AND DIED HAVING A STANDARD
SO THAT WE CAN WORK FROM THE
SAME SHEET OF MUSIC IT'S MUCH
BETTER THAN IF EVERYBODY'S
REFERRING TO A DIFFERENT SETS
OF STANDARDS. SEPARATELY WHEN
IT COMES TO WIDE THE SAM WHICH
IS THE STATE ADMINISTRATIVE
MANUAL COMPARING TO THE NEST
UNDER WHICH IS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL OR THE I SAW CENTER WHICH
IS MORE GLOBAL. IT'S S. PATEL
THE APPOINTED AL DIED THE
LARGER THE STANDARD IS BEING
CREATED. THE BROADER IT BECOMES
SO THAT IN MANY CASES YOU MIGHT
HAVE ITEMS THAT ARE COVERING
GLOBAL NEEDS THAT NOT
NECESSARILY NOT VERY SPECIFIC
TO A STATE OPERATION. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WHAT WE
DID IN FACT BACK INTO THE HOUSE
THE SISTINE WE ACTUALLY OF HAVE
THE CONTRACTED WITH GARTNER TO
DO WHAT IS CALLED A STANDARD
COMPARISON. LOOKING AT THE
ENTIRE STATE OF I STILL LOOK IN
AN ENTIRE SET OF THIS STATE
UNDER. IN MAPPING INTO WHAT
CALIFORNIA SAM SPECIFIC
STANDARD THAT WE REALLY IT'S
APPLICABLES TO THE OPERATION OF
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO IN
ORDER TO DO THAT THEN WE CAN
REALLY HELP PRIORITIZE THE
ALREADY LIMITED IN A RESOURCE
WHEN IT COMES TO MEDICATION.
DON'T JUST SOLVE PROBLEM BROAD
BUT MAKING THEM MORE MEANINGFUL
AND MORE TARGETED TO ADDRESSED
SO WITH THE ADOPTION OF SAM WE
WERE ABLE TO GO DEEPER. AND
HELPING THE DEPARTMENT TO GET
MATURE ON THOSE INSTEAD OF
ADDRESSING THINGS THAT MAY OR
MAY NOT BE RELEVANT. TO THEIR.
THIS OKAY AND I JUST BUT I KNOW
WE TALKED ABOUT THE YOUR TIME
AT THE MATURITY METRIC IN THE
AUDITS AND THE ASSESSMENT SENT
WOULD WOULD AND I KNOW THAT'S
WAS DEVELOPED INTERNALLY. AND
IT WOULD BASICALLY. RIGHT THE
IT DOES SECURITY MADE AT THAT
THE MAJORITY MATTER WITH SWISS
WITH SUPPORT FROM THE CALL FOR
AS WELL AS YOU KNOW GARDENERS
AND OTHER VENDORS THAT WE HAVE
SOLICITED SO THAT THAT MATURITY
METRIC I KNOW THE AUDITOR SAID
SOME OF THE NON REPORTING
ENTITIES AREN'T READY TO DO
THAT BUT IT ONCE IT GETS TO
THAT POINT IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE ADOPTABLE BY
OTHER THE CONSTITUTIONAL AS ARE
NOT REPORTING ENTITIES. THE
METRIC THAT YOU USE. RIGHT THE
THESE THE MATURITY METRIC IS
ACTUALLY ONE OF THOSE THINGS I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO SHARE WITH
ANYBODY IT UP. YOU KNOW WANTED
TO USE IT I DO AGREE WITH THE
AUDITOR'S ASIDE THAT THE FIRST
LINE IS TO ESTABLISH A
BASELINE. WHICH IS WHERE A LOT
OF ORIENTED HE STARTED WITH A
FEW YEARS BACK. BUT ONCE YOU
ESTABLISH THAT PLACE LINE
GIVING HOW FAST EVERYTHING HAS
EVOLVE IT'S DEAD IT'S REALLY
ABOUT KEEP NOT ONLY KEEPING UP
FOR COMPLIANCE BUT HOW DO YOU
TRYING TO BE PROACTIVE. AND GET
AHEAD OF IT AND BASS THE FOCUS
OF OUR OVERSIGHT CYCLE IS TO
ACHIEVE A MAJORITY. NOT ONLY
COMPLIANCE RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IF I COULD JUST FOLLOW UP
ON A COUPLE OF ISSUES THAT BEEN
RAISED. ON THE ISSUE OF
ADOPTION OF DIFFERENT STANDARDS
AYE YOU MENTIONED ABOUT THE
THREE STAND AS BEING. SAM BE
MORE SPECIFIC AND THIS BEING A
LITTLE MORE. I GUESS NATIONWIDE
AND ALSO I S. WILL BE MORE
GLOBAL. NOW DOES THE ADOPTION
OF SPECIFIC STANDARD IMPACT THE
ISSUE OF ALL INTEROPERABLE
EDDIE LET'S SAY. OF BETWEEN
FOLKS HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
WHOSE RACES OF THE SEASON AND
YOU KNOW SEEM EVEN SOME GLOBAL.
OF SERGIO ENTITIES. AND IF NOT
WHY NOT. AND IT GETS HERE FOR
THE CHAMPION I DOT THE YES
STOPS THE ADOPTION OF A
STANDARD IS SOMETHING THAT IS
MORE OF A USING WHAT TYPE OF
REFERENCE GUY. THAT YOU USE AND
HOW DO YOU MAKE YOURSELF BECOME
COMPLIANT OR MATURE TOWARDS
THAT STANDARD IS WHERE THE
ARTISTS BUT SIMPLY HAVING
ADOPTION OF THE STANDARD DOES
NOT IN MY OPINION WOULD HAVE
BEEN IN EFFECT OR IN A YOU KNOW
IMPEDING THE INTER OPERABILITY.
WHEN IT COMES TO INFORMATION
SHARING. TO ACT IN IDEALLY
SINCE WE PART PARTNER WITH SOME
OF THE FEDERAL PARTNERS VIA THE
MSI SACK AND VIA THE FEDERAL
PARTNERS VIA THE CAL SICK. THEN
THIS HAS BEEN KIND OF THE DE
FACTO STANDARD WHETHER IT'S IN
THIS STATE UNDER FIFTY THREE OR
THE NESTS YOURSELF SO THAT THAT
IS KIND OF OUR IDEAL
METHODOLOGY IS TO MAP MAP.
CALIFORNIA STANDARD TO THAT
FRAMEWORK JUST SO WE CAN INTER
OPERATE A LITTLE BIT BETTER
WITH PARTNERS WITHIN THE UNITED
STATES. WE HAVE NOT ADOPTED THE
ISEL STANDARD. FOR MANY REASONS
THE I. SO AS A STANDARD IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE BROAD AND IT
DOESN'T TAKE CARE OF CERTAIN I
GUESS PRIVACY OR CRYPTOGRAPHY
OR TRANSPARENCY ISSUES DO YOU
DO TO LAWS AND REGULATIONS THAT
OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE. AND THEN
SINCE THE I SO STANDARD APPLIES
INTERNATIONALLY THE PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T BE THE IDEAL STANDARD
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE WE HAVE ARE KINDA
UNIQUE. TRANSPARENCY AND
CRYPTOGRAPHY. STANCES IN LAWS.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY OF THOSE
THE ENTITIES THAT. BEEN SURVEY
OUR TOP TWO ONE OF WHICH HOW
MANY OF THE ENTITIES ADOPTED.
THE THREE ONE OF THE THREE. OR
IS DO YOU HAVE THAT INFORMATION
WHATEVER IS OUT QUESTION FOR
THE AUDITOR. THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'S PROBABLY A HE QUESTION
TODAY AUDITOR BECAUSE THEM. I'M
JUST WARNING YOU WONDERING WHY
DID ADOPTED CERTAIN STANDARD
AND I'D SAY. THE AG'S OFFICE
VERSUS ANOTHER CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICES ADOPTING DIFFERENT
STANDARDS YOU KNOW I I'M JUST
WONDERING WHAT THE RATIONALE
WAS IN DOING THAT IF. IT IS.
NEAR THE CELL IS UNDER THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AS WE PROBABLY
WOULDN'T WOULDN'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION IN BUT REALLY THE
ENTITIES WE DO OVERSEE. ARE ARE
WORKING. TOWARDS ADOPTING OUR
STANDARDS AS AS BEST AS THEY
CAN. YEAH LET ME ASK A QUESTION
THAT I ASKED OF THE ARE TURNED
OUT AS- COMPARISON BETWEEN
USING LET'S SAY THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARIES. OUR DEPARTMENT
VERSES THAT'S A PRIVATE ENTITY
OF AND THERE ARE THERE ANY
ADVANTAGES ADVANTAGES TO USING
ONE OVER THE OTHER THAT YOU
KNOW. IN YOUR VIEW. YEAH I CAN
I CAN ANSWER THAT AND
DEFINITELY THE ADVANTAGES TO.
ESSENTIALLY FOR USE ONE
CONTRACTOR TO DO OUR
INFORMATION SECURITY
ASSESSMENT. WILL HAVE MORE
CONSISTENCY IN THE DELIVERABLES
IN THE METRICS WE KEEP TRACK OF
BETWEEN DEPARTMENTS BETWEEN
AGENCIES AND KINDA TRENDING
YEAR OVER YEAR. IDEALLY I'D
LIKE TO STANDARDIZE AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. ON THE ONE CONTRACTOR
AND ARE KIND AND GO TO
CONTRACTOR RIGHT NOW IS THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT.
SO FOR CONSISTENCY SAKE IT IS
ADVANTAGEOUS TO USE WANT ONE
SET OF CONTRACTORS THAT DO A
REALLY GREAT JOB IN DELIVERING
WHAT THEY DO. IF I CAN ADD A
LITTLE BIT OF STATISTIC THIS IS
WERE PROVIDED BY STAFF SIDE IN
THE PAST TWO YEARS THERE WAS
ABOUT EIGHT AM INDEPENDENCE
SECURITY ASSESSMENT THAT WAS
CONDUCTED BY A PRIVATE
PROVIDER. AND SEVEN OUT OF
THOSE EIGHT DID NOT MEET THE
CRITERIA THAT WAS JOINTLY
DEVELOPED BY OUR CORE FOR
ENTITY IN TERM OF MEASUREMENTS
THE R. MEANINGFUL AND VALUABLE
AND CAN TRULY MEASURE THE SICK
THE MATURITY. I'M NOT ONLY TO
COMPLIANCE SO I AM I DEAD THAT
MAY BE DUE TO. YOU KNOW
MULTIPLE OF REASONS I DON'T
WANT TO SAY THAT'S BECAUSE OF
THAT THE OUTSIDE VENDOR SERVICE
IS NOT GOOD THAT'S NOT ONE
THING AT ALL BUT I WOULD SAY
THAT. EVEN IF THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD LIKE TO USE AN OUTSIDE
PROVIDER FOR THEIR INDEPENDENCE
SECURITY ASSESSMENT I WOULD
REALLY ENCOURAGE TO SPEND A TO
TAKE A LOOK THE PUBLISHED A
SECURITY MEASURE MAIN CRITERIA
SO THAT THEY COULD DO YOU KNOW.
FIRST TIME AROUND THEY COULD DO
A COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT FOR
THE DEPARTMENTS. AND THEN A AND
THEN ANOTHER ANOTHER REASON IS
COST COST EFFECTIVENESS I MEAN
I'VE BEEN IN INFORMATION
SECURITY OFFICER AT THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND ONLY I'VE USED
THIRD PARTY CONTRACTORS THIRD
PARTY VENDORS. AND FOR COST
EFFECTIVENESS PERSPECTIVE I
AGAIN SAY THAT THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT WAS MORE
MORE PROVIDED MORE VALUE FOR
WHAT WHAT. WE GOT. WHAT WE PAID
FOR. THANK YOU. HI I JUST. HAD
ONE OTHER THING IF. DID YOU DO
LOOK AT THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THE AUDITOR.
MENTIONED IS THAT THE
ASSESSMENTS SHOULD BE DONE THE-
NO LESS THAN EVERY THREE YEARS
ARE YOU ARE YOU ON THE LINE I
KNOW IT DEPENDS ON WHAT KIND OF
INFORMATION AND MATURITY THE
DEPARTMENT IS BUT ARGUED. MORE
INCLINED TO A TWO YEAR
ASSESSMENT OR TO A THREE YEAR
ASSESSMENT WERE BIRD MOST OF
YOUR DEPARTMENTS FALL. DESCRIBE
WHAT OUR CURRENT PRACTICE HAS
EVOLVED TO AND AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT WE ACTUALLY AND
AGAIN I MAYBE THIS IS A
CLARIFICATION WE CAN GET FROM
THE AUDITOR THAT THE ASSESSMENT
VERSUS THE HIGH RISK AUDIT.
BECAUSE THE ASSESSMENT THE WAY
WE CALL IT IS REALLY THE
INDEPENDENT SECURITY ASSESSMENT
IS WHAT MILITARY AT A TO
PROVIDE FOR OTHER THIRD PARTY
VENDOR IS MORE OF A PENETRATION
TESTING VERY TACTICAL AND
TECHNICAL WHAT TYPE OF SUSSMAN
WE DO HAVE THOSE BEING AS- AS-
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON EVERY TWO
YEARS. FOR THE ENTITIES ARE
UNDER OUR PURVIEW IN ADDITION
TO THAT DOLE WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED AND DID CHANGE FROM
A THREE YEAR CYCLE TO MORE OF A
FOUR YEAR CYCLE WILL BE CALLED
HIGH RISK AUDIT. THE AUDIT IS
MORE ON THE POLICY COMPLIANCE
AS OPPOSED TO TECHNICAL
COMPLIANCE BUT EVEN THOUGH WE
WENT FROM A THREE YEAR TO A
FOUR YEAR THAT'S WITH A EVERY
TWO YEAR WAS STILL WHAT IS CALL
A TOUCH BASE AUDIT. WHICH WOULD
BE MEANS IS THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT AFTER DEPARTMENT RECEIVED
THEIR- ASSESSMENT REPORT THE
ANY TIME TO REMEDIATE SO CABIN
A TWO AND A THREE YEAR
SOMETIMES DOESN'T GIVE ENOUGH
TIME FOR THESE DEPARTMENT TO
REMEDIATE THE FINDING. SO WE
MOVED TO FOR YEARS HOWEVER IN
THE FOUR YEAR CYCLE. YOU KNOW
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE SECOND
YEAR WE DO DO A I AM ONLY OF
TOUCH BASES TO WRITE A CHECK IN
YES I CANNOT. IT IS A
LIGHTWEIGHT ECONOMIC LIGHT
WEIGHT LIGHT LIGHT WENT ON. SO
THAT THE GOAL HERE IS TO HAVE
CONTINUOUS ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT SO DIED THEY'RE NOT
BEING THEY FEEL LIKE. THEY ARE
AN ISLAND ON THEIR OWN IN TERM
OF ACHIEVING OR WE MEDIATE A
FINDING. AND THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO BE YOU KNOW
MADE HERSELF AVAILABLE. IN
ADDITION TO THE- A SECOND YOUR
CHECK IN AND THEN THE FOURTH
YOUR AUDIT. THROUGHOUT THE FOUR
YEAR THERE'S ALSO ADVISORY
SERVICES THE ARE. THE ARE
PROVIDED TO THE DEPARTMENT SO
THAT WHEN THEY HAVE QUESTION OR
THE OR THEY NEED HELP TO HOW
TO. REMEDIATE CERTAIN THINGS WE
ALSO. AT SAID DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
EITHER FOR THIS PANEL FOR THE
PREVIOUS PANEL. SO IF THERE ARE
NO OTHER COMMENTS I WANT TO
THANK OUR PANELISTS FOR JOINING
US HERE TODAY. I'LL KUDOS TO
CDT I TOTALLY AGREE WITH THE
COMMENT BY THE AUDITOR
PREVIOUSLY ABOUT THE
IMPROVEMENTS AT C. T. HAS MADE
OVER THE YEARS. ARE LIKE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN I ALSO
REMEMBER THE TWENTY FIFTEEN
REPORT WHICH I. A SPELL LOT OF
TIME STUDYING AND I ALSO
REMEMBER THE SUBSEQUENT HEARING
THE OVERSIGHT HEARING. WAS NOT
AS NICE I GUESS TO PUT IT
MILDLY BUT I THINK CD CITY HAS.
ON MAY TREMENDOUS TRIED OVER
THE YEARS ALONG WITH THE THREE
CORE. ARMED PARTNERS I WANT TO
THANK HIM FOR JOINING US HERE
TODAY. THE THREE OTHER OF COURT
PARTNERS YES. AND GAL
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT.
ALSO CHP SO KUDOS TO ALL OF YOU.
AGAIN LET ME JUST AT SOME
CONCLUDING REMARKS. THE REPORT
AND THE DISCUSSION HERE TODAY
COMPLETELY VALIDATE CONCERN
SAID MY COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE
HAD REGARDING THE INFORMATION
SECURITY ON OF. A REPORT NON
REPORTING ENTITIES HOWEVER SOME
OF THESE ENTITIES HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO THROW ALL OUR
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS WITH WHAT
SEEMS TO BE A FUNDAMENTALLY
TERRITORIAL. ARGUMENT THEY
DON'T WANT CITY T. TO INFRINGE
ON THEIR INHERENT
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY. AND
THERE ANY FOR CONFIDENTIALITY
IF THEY WERE TO SUBMIT TO CDT
STANDARDS AND ASSESSMENTS. WELL
I DO UNDERSTAND IT DESIRE TO OF
FOR INDEPENDENCE AS CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE I CAUTION AGAINST
SO HAVING SUCH AN ATTITUDE WHEN
IT COMES TO AN ISSUE AS
IMPERATIVE. ALL TO THE SUCCESS
AND SECURITY OF OUR STATE AND
OUR CONSTITUENTS WHO AND TRUST
US WITH. THEIR INFORMATION
RESPECTFULLY MANY OF THESE
OFFICES HAVE CORE FUNCTIONS
THAT ARE WHOLLY SEPARATE FROM
THE AREA OF INFORMATION
SECURITY AND CYBERSECURITY.
HELLO MISTER ENSURE THAT NO
ENERGY ACROSS THE STATE A LACKS
THE LEVEL OF EXPERTISE IN FOCUS
THAT IT'S NOT NECESSARY IN
SETTING APPROPRIATE STATEWIDE
STANDARDS. IN ASSESSING
READINESS AGAINST ATTACKS. I AS
I'VE SAID MANY TIMES BEFORE
STATE REALLY NEEDS TO CONTINUE
STRENGTHENING WHAT HAS BEEN AN
INCREASINGLY COLLABORATIVELY L.
APPROACH. WHEN IT COMES TO
INFORMATION SECURITY AND ALSO
CYBERSECURITY. AGAIN OF OUR
CORE CYBERSECURITY PARTNERS CD
T. O. U. S. CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT AND C. H. P. R. HAVE
DONE A TREMENDOUS JOB. SO I
BELIEVE THE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT A SUPPORTS THAT
CONCLUSION ICE AS I STATED
EARLIER. ALL BUT THREE SO ONLY
SO MUCH HOW COOL PARTNERS CAN
DO WITH INCOMPLETE INFORMATION
AND IF WE WANT TO GIVE OUR
STATE THE BEST CHANCE OF
PROTECTING ITSELF. AND
CONSTITUENTS AGAINST ANY
INCREASING AND NEW THREATS IN
CYBER SECURITY WE HAVE TO
INTEREST AND SURE OF STATES
CORPS CYBERSECURITY EXPERTS.
ARE ACTS ARE ALREADY COOLEY A
POWER TO DO SO. OF COURSE I
RECOGNIZE THERE IS NO SILVER
BULLET SOLUTION TO INSULATE
OKAY OURSELVES IN THE MODERN
WORLD HOWEVER THERE ARE MANY
WAYS THAT WE CAN INCREASE OUR
DETECTION CAPABILITIES IMPROVE.
IMPROVE OUR RESPONSES AND ALSO
MEDICAID THE HARMS. ALL I THINK
THE FIRST STEP SO HAVE TO BE
CENTERED ON COMPLETE
INFORMATION GATHERING
CONDUCTING REGULAR ASSESSMENTS
ACROSS ALL STATE ENTITIES. AND
ALSO IMPLEMENTING UNIFORM
STANDARDS ACROSS THE STATE TO
REDUCE THE CHANCES OF A BAD
ACTOR. EXPLOITING THE WEAKNESS
OF ONE ENTITY TO PREACH OTHERS.
A TO THAT AND WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
WE CLOSE ANY GAPS AND PROVIDE
CD T. AND THE OTHER CORE
CYBERSECURITY PARTNERS. WITH AS
COMPLETE AS A PICTURE AS
POSSIBLE WITH RESPECT TO
INFORMATION SECURITY AND OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND HOPEFUL
THAT THAT WE CAN WORK TOGETHER
TO COME UP WITH THAT THE RIGHT.
SOLUTION PARTICULARLY AFTER
TODAY'S HEARING SO WITH THAT I
WILL TURN IT OVER TO. ARMS
BAZAR WHEN IF SHE HAS ANY
CONCLUDING. COMMENTS BEFORE WE
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS I'D I
DON'T REALLY HAVE OF ANYTHING
TED YOU'VE REALLY THAT SAID
EVERYTHING THAT'S A- THE EGG
COVERED EVERYTHING IMPORTANT
BUT I DO WANT TO THANK ONCE
AGAIN DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
FOR YOUR WORK AND- ALWAYS
APPRECIATES THE AUDITOR. AND
HOW MUCH ASSISTANCE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS OF FROM THE
AUDITOR AND LOOKING TO MAKE
SURE. THAT WE ARE FULLY. OF. IN
OUR ROLE OF OVERSIGHT OF WE
COULDN'T THAT WITHOUT AUDITOR'S
PARDON SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT FOR THE TIME AND FOR
CONTINUING TO FOCUS ON THIS.
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
PANELISTS AND LET'S OPEN UP OUR
PUBLIC COMMENTS ON SECTION IF
TO. ANYBODY OUT THERE IN THE
AUDIENCE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD. SEEING
NONE LAST CALL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR A FOR BEING HERE
MEETING ADJOURNED